You dirty freak bitches.
God,
we missed you.
We missed you so much.
We're back.
Ladies and gentlemen,
with this episode of the Joe Rogan
experience podcast,
also known as the Brian Red Band
experience is brought to you by.
Powerful.
Yeah.
Reddit.
That's uh,
that was awesome.
So that's pretty bad ass internet
communities are fucking amazing.
We live in awesome times.
That just means alone.
I mean how many funny fucking meme.
So you get to read everything from
really,
you know,
anytime anything happens,
science is really meet are really
amazing.
That bill burr was.
I saw that like a 100 times whatever the
quote was,
the ridiculous close scientist science.
Incredible.
Something like that.
I don't have his phone.
I was trying,
I was trying to get ahold of him because
I wanted to get him and Carrie Santa
Maria tonight together to do a podcast.
He's around.
I'll,
I'll give you.
I'll get you his number.
Well,
I'll ask him first.
That's the proper thing.
Do you not like it Brian County?
When people give away your phone number
and you get a phone call and it's like,
blocked me.
Pick it up at some goofball,
one
to talk to you and you're like,
Oh,
when?
When Jimmy Burke gave my number on your
podcast,
I got like 50,
but it's all been really cool.
I was like,
look,
don't you don't abuse my number?
And they'd be talking like,
what the fuck man?
I was like,
all right young guys.
All right guys.
I remember being used.
So yeah,
look,
99 point nine percent of all people are
cool.
I mean that sounds crazy but are out on
the road when I,
when I,
when I want people to come some nights
there,
they helped me out in a car rental.
I'll get my number,
I'll go,
just call me.
I'll get to healthcare with free
tickets.
Not once.
If I hadn't had anybody abuse it.
Not,
no.
Most people don't.
Most people are cool about it,
but I used to.
I fucked up once and twittered my
number.
It's a whole difference I was trying to
do.
He did somebody else I forget.
I was trying to send a buddy of mine my
number when new number it was.
I don't remember who I did is I fucked
up instead of hitting the reply to a
direct message,
somehow know that was a tweet.
Yeah.
I got a number from Jamaica and I was
like,
what is this?
I got got to answer it and I swear to
God I.
I'm not exactly.
I'm sure a lot of listeners have
probably gotten this,
but I probably hit.
Everybody goes,
yeah,
yeah.
Looking for a you,
you've won a prize.
Really terrible.
I was like,
I haven't because you won two point $5,
million dollars.
I just need some.
I just need some,
some tax money from you.
One percent of that.
Then you can have the money.
Can I?
Can I give you a tracking number?
No.
I was like,
yes,
and it gets me.
I go and he goes,
can you read it back to me?
I read it back.
Oh,
this is exciting.
I go,
how much I want to get to a point.
5 million.
Congratulations.
How'd you feel?
I feel amazing.
This is incredible because all you have
to do is just now we're going to have
to.
You have to pay the international tax,
that's all it is.
So just a while ago.
So I only have to be one percent of two
point $5.
Million Dollars I think is $250,000,000.
Thousand Dollars.
I don't know.
I'm really nervous.
I'm not sure,
but that's all I got to do is know
Justin fucked.
I'm going to ask you for $25,000.
How does that sound to you?
I go,
this is incredible.
And it goes I.
and then he gives me a bunch of other
information and I'm like,
I'm so excited.
I just feel like,
what did I do to get this?
He goes,
you ended that sweepstakes,
the worst job in the world.
Right?
And finally I go,
let me ask you a question,
how long I should have it?
I was,
I was eating at a Pf Chang's.
I was like,
oh fucking dumb.
Do you think he goes,
Bob Claude?
And he just hung up.
He just swore then pot pot English.
Well he's mad that he couldn't scam you,
but I mean you got a little better at
scamming then telling me.
I got a huge prize.
What's incredible is that that works.
I mean,
it's incredible.
I don't,
I do not remember who was telling us,
but someone had a friend that got Dan.
I wish I remember who the hell it was,
but anyway,
he was saying that was it already?
Was it already the total assist that he
knew a dude that thought,
I think it was already knew a dude that
thought he won,
you know,
some crazy price like this because you
got scammed by these Nigerian guys.
And it started getting really cunty
like,
yeah,
you guys wait,
wait to see what I got common like.
And they were like,
oh my God,
you were saying all this while you're
getting scammed by these Nigerian
Nigerians set up fake offices and a lot
of them are lawyers and a lot of them
are really educated and so I'll set up a
fake.
They weren't,
they were swinging the Big Wall Street
guys for a while.
Oh my God,
it's so crazy for cash,
for cash because the Wall Street guy get
greedy and say,
you know,
you want have to pay taxes on this,
but they'd have these offices that have
all set up.
They have,
it'd be with Nigerian oil company,
a subsidiary,
and there was a big article.
Scotland Yard was all over these guys
because.
And the FBI because they wiped out.
They really did a good job.
They had some young guys who were
traders give them $2,000,000.
This one guy mortgaged his house and he
killed himself window that he a lot.
Some people can just get.
What they would do is they would give
you money,
they would give you.
They do something like give you money
and then you would give them legit money
or something.
Whatever it was.
There were a lot of things to do and
you'd get home with this money in some
cases.
I'm not remember the exact story,
but the money was a fake die that would
wear off like in the movies,
you know,
like it was a,
some kind of a fake.
I don't know.
I have no idea,
but it was just a.
They realized that they were,
they were,
that,
that had been scammed of a million
dollars in jump out the window.
Commercials are an unnecessary evil or a
necessary evil.
Unnecessary.
You have to pay for bandwidth.
We're almost,
we're almost at high speed bandwidth
folks this week,
this week,
so hopefully it's all done.
So I know the,
uh,
people complain that the Ustream version
looks kind of poopy.
We can't really show you high if we
showed it in higher definition are shit
with crash.
It's whack.
I'm pretty striking.
And Idev is beautiful.
Tight skin.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience
podcast is brought to you by ting.
If you've never heard of Tim before,
I've never heard us talk about it.
It's an excellent alternative to a lot
of the,
uh,
what is okay?
I don't see smoking some money.
Get some weed,
man.
What the fuck is that?
It's a spoon spoon.
Brendan Walsh drunk.
Brendan's hammered with his phone is in
love with this phone.
Is he selling?
You know what Brendan Right now is
texting a guy that pretending to be a
girl that's going on right there.
That's why he's in love.
Make it hilarious tweets right now.
Tim has all the high end android phones.
If you,
um,
you know,
like we've talked about this before on
the podcast a.
unfortunately there's no other way to
say it,
but if you used to back in the day,
if you had a smartphone other than an
iphone,
you were a fool.
Like you really were a fool.
Like if you had one of those
blackberries storms.
I had one of those pieces of shit.
It was terrible.
Davidoff Helena is,
they call me out last year.
He goes about a year,
a quick,
let's do this.
I fonts.
Fantastic.
Oh,
is it?
Oh really?
Hey,
you heard this new thing called cars you
fall.
Are you still riding the horse for the
longest time?
If you had anything else?
It was poop.
But now not so much the,
uh,
the samsungs actually are for the first
time ever.
They're out selling the iphones.
These,
these,
the options of the larger screens,
the Samsung Galaxy s three,
like the differences size of the Brian
screen with the cat on it mean the other
cats though.
The cool desk squad cat.
I mean that is a goddamn enormous and
they're really fast.
I had an old,
an old early version android phone and
it was kind of clunky and Shitty,
but this a samsung galaxy s three.
It's amazing.
And that there's an s four that's coming
out now too.
Um,
and then they also have.
What's even cooler is the note that note
is amazing.
What is that?
Oh,
it's fucking huge.
Is this five inch phone you couldn't
write on it really?
They're like fucking computers.
Their tablets and phones all in one.
One of my first memories of view and we
heard the,
one of the first times we ever hung out
as I came out to see you.
And I had no idea you were such a tech
nerd fighter.
Like know this guy I talked to and we
were,
we went looking for pit bulls were
idiots.
Right?
So,
but you were like so techie.
I kind.
I see these computers.
You were on the Internet.
I didn't know what the hell that was and
then you go,
hold on,
I gotta go to this,
we've got to fries or something and you
get memory and you pop up on your
computer and you put memory chips into
your computer like you did it yourself.
And I remember being like,
this dude's I made that computer.
I didn't even own a computer when you
did that back then.
That was like for awhile as I would make
my own computers.
I was proud of that.
Yeah.
Yeah,
he was,
he was back in before anybody.
He had huge computer screens,
like you had a whole buy monitors and
then hook them up as computer screen.
Do you remember the first time?
I prefer it before I knew you could get
shit on the Internet.
He's,
I hear in my head and I'm like,
what are you doing?
He was out down and I'm like,
why is he keeping me out of his
computer?
And he stopped laughing what?
And he goes and he come and you come
running out and I go,
what are you doing?
He goes,
okay,
run in there and look now and I go
running and he and I hear you're going
here and as I go,
I see this ass on the screen and I'm
like,
why is that a big ass on the screen?
This is like weird and all of a sudden I
see this Japanese guy with his hair
pulled back like a Samurai and he's
going,
oh,
underneath the ass.
I go,
oh,
okay.
I guess he's going to eat her ass
sweater.
Oh,
guess what?
Here comes some poor ladies and
gentlemen,
and the guy pulled out of the girl
though,
and Joe's going,
he's laughing,
but go ahead.
It
was and he made them wait.
So it would download was.
Yeah,
I had a t one installed in my house back
then.
Remember that God,
it was such a retard.
I had a t one line installed in my
house.
I used to ask you to go to pit bull
websites.
It's like dogs because I just had to
throw away a lot of my computers and it
was so sad because you would go through
and look at all the video cards and look
how cool they looked back then and
they're just shit now.
You know,
your iphone is a million times faster
than that video cards.
So really incredible,
isn't it?
If you think about like back in the
quake two days,
like quake two,
I used to have what was called a two
video cards in sli formation mean
they're both linked up.
You have to separate video cards and
they linked together through this
computer cable and it doubles your,
your bandwidth as far as the ability to
offer that to you.
Dragged me.
Could he get fucking candles?
Are Guns for the quake thing?
Like the special kind of animals?
I was.
No,
no,
no.
You play quake with a mouse and
keyboard.
Yeah.
There was something you were playing
where I had to,
we had to get.
There's a while.
Yeah.
You know what?
I had a controller called the something
three deed and had a track ball and uh,
a gun on it as well.
It's really cool.
I came with them.
He's like,
I gotta get this,
but the track balls just not quite as
accurate.
There was some guys that were really
good with that controller,
but the thing was about that controller,
it was very controversial because you
didn't.
If you learn how to use that control and
then you wouldn't be good at the mouse.
And the keyboard,
which was widely accepted by almost
everybody to be the most accurate way.
Some guys get really good at using the
control,
but there were still fucking themselves
by not just going with a mouse and
keyboard.
Would you do what you do a live quake
match in front of an audience?
Every says Kevin prayer.
Yeah,
sure.
that'd be fun.
And comic con 2000.
Well,
if I can,
I mean it all depends on the phone if I
can,
but you don't have to train for it and
know that's the problem.
The problem is if I started training,
I would get obsessed again.
Yeah.
But you.
But you don't know the rush gets crazy
rush of getting really
good at quake is it's so intense because
you're playing in these three d games
where you're running down hallways,
you have a variety of weapons on you and
you're chasing motherfuckers trying to
kill them and when you kill them they
splatter,
you're shooting rockets at them and it's
all in real time and the graphics are
amazing and you're seeing it through a
first person perspective.
Either you're seeing a gun in front of
you or seemed crosshairs in front of
you,
but you're manipulating the character
and the better you get at your hand eye
coordination and your understanding of
maps,
the more effectively you can just fuck
people up.
Like there's many,
many,
many levels and video game skills.
And I never got really good.
I got good for a regular person.
Yeah.
But I never got like really good.
But I played some really good guys and
just got slow
when I was doing my,
uh,
when I was doing a hang,
not hang over a ride along that movie I
shot in uh,
in Atlanta with ice cube and Kevin Hart.
I would go into Kevin Hart's a trailer
all the time because it would just hang
out in these hilarious and he'd be,
he and his buddies would be taking that
madden basketball game so far.
King seriously,
like,
stay like serious,
like serious,
like competition
games and get pissed off at each other
if they lost.
Like,
and they're really a tight group.
They love each other.
It was war.
That fucking game was war.
I come in,
Hey Kevin,
we plan.
I wouldn't even eat.
They're addictive.
Yeah,
it's super different.
I,
I don't fuck around with them anymore.
I still play pool.
I don't fuck around with video games
anymore,
but I am still addicted to technology,
which is why like I said,
we uh,
we're,
we're really into ting with tim.
Tim provides a is not just the greatest
android phones available,
but we also,
they also provide contract free cell
phone service on a major network.
It's on the sprint backbone,
so it's not like you're not in a mom and
pop network.
You're on a,
you know,
a huge network and you can do that with
no contracts and the way a sprint has
it,
not only other,
no contracts,
but they give you credit on unused
service.
So if you use less than you would on
Tang sprint.
Sprint,
yeah.
Well they're using sprint.
Sprint doesn't have the.
Yeah.
Well don't go to sprint.
Take Jesus Christ who lets us get high
and do commercials.
I want to know.
I don't know whose idea that was
laughing because there's so many
entering and so on.
They're awesome.
Yeah.
I'm ting.
Anyway,
go to [inaudible] dot ting.com
and you can save yourself 25 bucks off
of either one of their phones or one of
their or their service.
And what I was saying was that 10 gives
you credit on unused service.
So if you use less than you thought you
would,
ting actually drops you down and,
and credits you the difference on your
next bill.
I mean,
that's unheard of.
Companies never give you the money back.
That's the ethical way to do it.
And what they realized is you can still
make money and provide people
a great service and you know,
you don't have to fuck people over.
You don't have to rip them off and you
can do things in a generous way.
And that's,
that's how [inaudible] operates.
And I love that.
I think it's,
it's a,
it's a great ethic.
And when you see a company that has,
you know,
that that's how they're operating their
business,
it makes you feel good about being
connected to them.
It makes you feel good about,
about what,
what message they're projecting about
that,
like the ethical,
you know,
I just got sponsored to buy ting,
the Brian callen show,
the bride cat got some good guests.
I'm not to mention the 10 minute
podcast,
but um,
uh,
the,
the Ting,
I,
when,
when they came to me,
I said to myself,
you know,
I knew there were a good company for
you,
so I was like,
that's great.
But then I thought,
you know,
if you get a sponsored by,
uh,
you know,
somebody wants to offer you a lot of
money,
say you're podcast becomes huge and
somebody and some,
sometimes companies can become so big
and you're not sure where their
interests are,
what they're doing it,
it really does kind of raise some
questions.
I don't want to be responsible for
supporting or,
or shelling a company that doesn't have
ethical practices,
you know,
it's a hard one,
but you don't have to anymore.
There's,
there's plenty of really good companies
and I think,
I think a lot of these companies also
operating on the Internet.
The Internet is pretty transparent.
It's not,
it's not difficult to compare rates and
services and that with cars,
man.
People.
No,
no.
You know,
it's like.
And they also know that it's an.
He taught every company has enough to
squeeze every last blood out of.
You know,
when you have something that it's
required,
a service like cell phone service,
it becomes that weird,
creepy thing where they've got you.
You fucking need them.
Okay.
You know you need that.
It's right.
You need the mic.
Me.
Mcdonald's says that they have.
They never turned anybody but like a
hamburger meaning.
So you go in and say,
I don't like my hamburger.
That give you a free one.
Why the hamburger?
A lot of people say,
well,
you walk in and you're not a $2
hamburger.
The average customer in Mcdonald's
spends I think about $53,000
over a lifetime on Mcdonald's.
They're loyal customers.
So when you walked through that door,
you're,
you're worth $53,000.
That's an interesting way of living.
And so they treat you like a person,
not a hamburger.
They don't treat you do it because they
want to be nice.
How about that?
Oh,
that Mcdonald's,
you fucking county number count and
assholes.
That's ridiculous.
How many you just do it because you
don't treat someone like they're $50,000
that some companies like starbucks from
what I understand,
is very responsible socially.
Like they,
they're very intent on using the money
to make our,
to,
you know,
to it.
It's a big responsibility and I think
that you're right.
I mean just how about doing it because
it's the right thing to do.
I just,
I,
you know,
it just makes me happy to work with
companies that I know are not douchey.
I'm.
So that's how I feel about tank.
Go to [inaudible] dot [inaudible] dot
com.
Save yourself some money.
I'm also,
we're brought to you by squarespace.
Squarespace is one of our newer
sponsors.
If you've never been a and don't know
what it is.
Squarespace is an all in one inclusive
platform online for the average regular,
everyday smell like you or me son to go
and create their own website and it's
pretty fucking bad ass.
And uh,
you know,
when I first got my very first website,
a dude named menthol created it for me.
Menthol did most of my websites.
No,
I got to get in touch with him and he he
got,
he got super busy.
You had a lot of things going on in his
personal life into when he was a guy
used to play quake with an extreme
detriment.
We had a quick glance and you can train
you.
Her name was extreme.
A little bit better than me.
When we played quick.
He always just a little bit better than
me.
He was good.
He played really good.
We can have a comedy show podcast going
around you while you're.
I am terrified of.
It sounds so ridiculous,
but I'm terrified of becoming addicted
to playing video games going and you get
excited about.
I don't even know if you just get.
I love when you get really excited one
time.
Remember you were like,
you were like,
we were like 30 and you're like,
look at this t shirt.
There was a ufc tee shirts,
like a fight,
this race car,
this thing,
this is a workout.
It's a book and then he just.
There was a pause and you go,
I'm 12.
So fucking great because we're all
looking at you.
Like I didn't work kind of idiots too,
but Jesus wasn't overboard.
Really excited over a designer on a tee
shirt.
Dude,
I'd get really good
excited about the newest video games
coming out.
I've always been very child.
Just replace your pool obsession with
your quake,
obsessing with the kids more.
Don't want to do it.
And they were like,
no,
I'm not.
I don't go.
I played pool maybe one night a week if
that.
Do you remember when we were.
We were hunting and,
and I remember I think you said or
something.
I was like,
I don't need a lot of sleep out here
because we,
we're,
we're so not like I really.
The amount of stimulus we're exposed to,
we're inundated.
It's crazy.
We're not designed for this,
that's for sure.
We're.
We were designed for what you
experienced when you go camping.
That's what we're designed for.
We're designed to take in nature.
We're not designed for Times Square.
The human body does not know what the
fuck to do with Times Square.
The human body sees giant billboards and
just goes,
oh,
your whole system is out of whack.
You're like,
Oh fuck,
am I even looking at what about you?
Well,
what am I looking at when I'm going to
the movies?
What am I looking at when I'm,
what am I dealing with?
And I'm listening to songs that,
the input that we received today,
so we're not designed for any of this
shit.
Our bodies not caught up to what
technology can do you fucks.
That's why they.
There's one theory about autism kids,
kids who have hyperactive minds and,
and um,
central nervous systems that maybe we're
evolving.
We're literally evolving with technology
because I totally believe that.
I totally believe that it makes sense.
I mean,
I think it's terrifying for people
because we love our emotions,
but I think the reality is we're
probably going to eventually outgrow
them.
Oh Shit.
Did I say that I was having fun alive.
I've
squarespace.
You're dirty fox.
Keep hope alive.
This was supposed to be an ad.
I'm making a website right now.
We went off the rails pretty cool.
You could just pretty much pick a theme,
what you want your website to look like
out of a bunch of different things.
And then like if you're watching right
now,
I'm just pretty much making a website
as you sit here talking to me.
Yeah.
It's so ridiculously easy to say.
You just hit this to change the title.
Okay.
Look at this.
All right.
When she a fucking love it.
I want to do it.
I should trade to create my own website.
And that's now the name of your new
website.
Yeah,
it's my new website.
I like it.
That's a good.
That's a catchy blog title.
I want Dolphin butthole.
I mean who could forget that sooner or
that guy has got something to say.
CASTA squarespace.com.
Forward Slash Joe.
Go there.
Look at that.
Now no credit card is needed.
But if try it out and you can start
building your website.
And then if you decide to purchase
squarespace,
use the offer code Joe Three and get 10
percent off your first purchase on new
accounts,
including monthly and annual plans.
Um,
squarespace has built in a ecommerce
abilities that's really a bad ass and
easy to use.
Super easy to set up your own online
store.
You could do it ridiculously fast.
And I'm the,
they offer 24 slash seven support.
Responsive design.
Your site will look great on any device.
Like you can have it on an iphone,
an IPAD,
a computer.
It's gonna look sweet.
They know what the fuck they're doing.
I mean,
it's really incredible.
The.
This used to be so hard to do.
My God,
making a website at one point in time
was just completely outside of the realm
of my,
my even thinking.
Brian just made a website.
Okay,
look,
I want dolphin butthole.
There it is.
Okay.
He just did that.
He made a fucking website.
I mean in the time we're doing this,
this conversation,
he made a website that shit's real.
And look,
I could make a store right now I guess
manage products and now I'm selling
Dolphin Butthole Lube.
I forgot to tweet that.
I'm doing the job
bikes and skis and shit.
He just started selling skis from his
store.
This is madness.
This is like World War z.
But with technology it's not zombies,
but it's websites.
They're just fucking.
Every 12 seconds you've got a new one.
Anyway,
go to squarespace.squarespace.com.
Excuse me,
that's squarespace.com
forward slash joe and use the offer code
Joe and the number three and you can get
10 percent.
Is it number four now?
Because it's April.
Oh,
it's April,
right?
Yeah,
he probably use for use for Jesus
Christ,
but use it.
It's cool company and a cool product and
it really works.
You know,
so if you're looking make your own
website.
I say go fall.
I bet.
I think it's interesting to your your
advertising things.
I wanted to say to your fans,
you guys liked to laugh.
I don't know if any of you out there
that you do in a show.
Anyway.
Brian Campbell is a weird question.
I am in fact this Friday,
Saturday and Sunday at laugh out loud
and San Antonio,
Texas.
Laugh out loud.
Lol.
San Antonio Dot com for tickets.
You best?
It's San Antonio.
It's a gangster town's website.
If you're listening to this later,
has always tour dates,
podcasts,
photos and videos on it and it's just
Brian Cohen.com.
And listen to 10 minute podcasts in the
Brian Cowen show.
We got a good one to 10 minute podcast.
I talked about and I confessed to
killing a dolphin and the boys have to
talk me off the ledge.
That's not true.
I would never do that,
but I'm on the Brian Council.
I did interview a really interesting guy
and it's up now.
Vincent Labarbera,
who is a defense lawyer could fit.
Let's talk about it.
Let's get through this commercial I'm
talking about.
Yeah.
I would love to.
This.
This is going to be missing from the
Sirius satellite broadcast.
He's a bad ass enough data on INC com.
So last sponsor.
We're at a chimp kettlebells.
Sorry.
No,
I won't listen.
I told you motherfuckers.
Okay.
It's hard.
Hard to make these things hard to keep
these bitches and stock.
They went flying out because there's.
They're so cool looking.
I went,
by the way.
You know why I'm a good friend because I
don't call you up and say,
I saw that night.
I don't know who to give me some chimp
Kettlebell.
No,
I'm buying them.
I'm like,
everybody else.
I'm getting one to Donald Cowboy cerrone
to.
I wanted my man right there.
Look,
it needs to be given away to some people
that she was just too cool not to have.
It looks like a chimp biting off your
Dick.
That is the chimp biting off your Dick
face and do for motivation for
motivation and your workouts.
You know,
you could hold the kettle bells like
that,
looking at the chimp and then drop it
down to your Dick and then push away.
Drop the guys your Dick and they push,
motivate.
It can be the new kettle bell routine
like the,
uh,
the chimp bite your Dick kip ups or
something there.
I just read a book called our inner ape
and he talks about how we're a bipolar,
a bunny comparisons to chimps and
gorillas,
but one of the things that they use
today at a circus of thing where they
had a chimp that they muscled and they
took strong men and tried to control
that chimp trying to wrestle with it.
None of them.
None of that.
It's got four hands look forehands yeah,
and the amount of strength five times
the point.
We don't even understand it.
It's just we think,
well,
they're about our size,
so you know,
like,
you know,
you're dealing with something completely
different.
It's just completely different.
But if you want to get chimps drawn,
go get yourself some other shit that we
have.
We have regular kettlebell still like
the God that was April fool's fucking
foul and Joey Diaz fucking Kettlebell.
That's so ridiculous.
I love it.
I want it.
We have a club bells.
We started selling those now and Chin up
bars and all kinds of different fitness
shit.
And uh,
of course,
a lot of great fitness supplements
including hemp force,
the delicious and nutritious hemp
protein supplement and as raw maca and
raw or raw cocoa and MCA.
And um,
it's sweetened with Stevia.
Says very little sugar.
There's only one gram of sugar in a full
serving.
It's fucking delicious.
Super good for you.
And we have to get it from Canada
because our county twat bad government
says it's illegal to grow the non
psychoactive version of his marijuana.
You can't grow it.
So these silly bitches,
so we have to buy it from Canada.
But,
uh,
it's super good for you.
It really easy to digest.
I love it.
In the morning,
if I don't have the time to put together
a Kale shake,
I'm just fucking running out the door.
I take one of those seats.
Oil,
coconut waters.
I throw in some hemp force.
Boom.
It's not like a lot of food,
but it gives,
it fills me up.
It's nutritious.
It's easy to digest,
it's super easy to digest.
You getting some nutrition,
like couldn't attrition in a,
in a small forum.
And it's great after workouts too.
Anyway.
[inaudible] DOT com.
Oh.
And,
and it,
um,
if you use the code name Brogan,
you will save 10 percent off any and all
supplements.
All right,
we got through it.
Brian.
Counselor,
we're going to.
We're already getting busy.
So it's a place that music first right
now.
Oh yeah.
My voice is.
His name is breakable beats and you can
find them on sound,
sound speeds.
And it really starts off putting because
it talks about.
And then it goes right into the,
here's the,
here's the breakdown being terrible.
That's hilarious.
That is one of the most surprising
things about podcasting is the amount of
cool shit that people do on their own.
You know,
people
create funny.
A youtube compilations
did I have these guys in San Antonio and
I can't remember the name there.
I'm going to try to find them to give a
shout out,
but they tweaked them to be in San
Antonio and these guys create a whole
video devoted to Brian Callan and,
and no console out.
No consequences,
no guns allowed.
And I was dying.
They made like a three minute,
like really well done.
Put together videos.
So commercial for you?
Yeah.
They made a commercial for me and on
twitter and it's trying to find them
because they were so awesome.
And uh,
and anyway,
I'll,
I'll just give a shout out when we,
but I mean that's what the internet
does.
You get a bunch of guys who are like,
dude,
let's make a video for them advertising.
I was,
I was dying.
You guys are coming to my show for free
by the way.
Just come up to me and telling me that
you did it.
Not everybody will be like,
yeah,
you got to say,
are you getting any proof man?
Need to do another one?
Right.
I know the guys,
but I know what they look like.
It's a great thing,
man.
It's great.
Democratizing force and I have a
beautiful voice.
I didn't realize that.
So I think they put some of that fucking
crazy shit and electronic music thing.
What's it called?
Yeah,
Auditorium.
They all turned the fuck out of.
You know,
they didn't decide.
I say Jay Z,
who uses that auto tune shit t pain.
I think I sound like Josh Groban.
I don't even know what that guy sounds
like.
I when I read it,
yes you do.
I'm trying to find.
I would not be able to pick it out of a
lineup and you know,
if you played it for me,
it wasn't him.
You would get me.
You can sell me a fucking album with
johnny to tone from down the block
saying,
if you could be one rock'n'roll front
man of all time,
what would it be?
Oh Jesus.
It's tough to fuck with David Lee Roth.
It's tough to fuck with diamond.
Dave about it,
like when it comes to front man,
dude,
there was some years in the 19 eighties,
like 84 85 through the jump era,
they dominated,
dominated,
which was incredible.
I mean,
it's no wonder they broke up.
They,
they,
they were hitting it so hard.
Of course they all lost their mind.
I spent time at Diamond Dave.
Oh yeah.
And
He,
uh,
he had some real,
had real conversations like three,
like two hours long.
And he,
because he used to rent up David Offs,
the apartment above David,
he had a building dove had and he used
to rent from Doug Davidoff above him and
he basically would practice karate.
He had his helicopters license.
He was an emt,
a real dramatic and saved lives.
He'd be,
he had to pull somebody out of a car and
they'd be like,
you're David diddly wrong buck.
And he was like,
ah,
but he told us these great stories and
um,
he,
he like,
he's very,
very spartan,
like he has a bowl and a and
sometimes he'd sleep on the roof outside
in a tent.
He's just a real like,
you know,
that's very unusual day.
He's not in debt money or anything.
It's got living in a really small
apartment in Tokyo now.
There it is.
He came on the podcast and talk to us
about.
He's been living in Tokyo for 10 months.
Really?
Yeah.
This is what a trip this guy is.
He was.
They were going to do some shows in
Tokyo and I go,
how many flight for how long?
He's like,
we're going to do about two weeks in
Tokyo.
I'm like,
okay.
He went for 10 months.
For 10 months.
He said that Eddie got sick and so when
they had to postpone,
it took a long time for them to be able
to reschedule because it's a big tour.
Sure.
So when Eddie got second and they
rescheduled,
he said,
well,
Hey,
I'll just go over there and see what
it's like.
So he fucking moves to Tokyo.
He used to Kayak around Manhattan.
Yeah.
What are you gonna do today?
I'm going to Kayak around Manhattan.
The crack around Manhattan,
the island of Manhattan Kayak in the
river.
He's.
He does what he wants when he's taken
sword classes.
Oh yeah.
That's what he's doing is taking sword
fighting classes and learning Japanese.
So he came over here.
He's speaking Japanese and telling them,
telling us about his fucking sword
fight.
He's 58.
Well he refers to karate is cut out to
my favorite when I studied get out to
for many years.
In fact I studied so long.
I feel as though I am good at.
Well he has a legit martial arts
background.
There's no doubt about that.
Like he,
he definitely liked.
I remember he would throw kicks,
like when he would do shows,
I'm like,
that guy can move his fucking box.
Can do the splits.
Yeah.
He would throw these crazy high kicks in
and you're like,
Holy Shit.
Like you can't.
Like the way he was throwing kicks was
like a guy who's trained martial arts
and seriously,
yeah.
Yeah.
A lot in and trained very hard in really
good shape.
He's in great shape,
man.
It's just,
it's interesting to meet a guy like
that.
It's like this 58 year old sorta.
God just still does whatever the fuck
you want to go to Japan,
you know,
fuck it.
I think.
Yeah,
I think what happens though,
when you,
when you've hit the apex of fame,
like when you're a rock star on his
level,
you're the biggest that you don't get
more famous than that.
You just don't on earth on earth,
on earth man.
And uh,
and,
and just to play the stadiums and just
they go crazy.
And I think once you do that and you're,
you kind of,
if you're an interested person in the
world,
you realize that it's like you get
immune to that.
You actually,
I think you'd get immune to it.
I think you'd get immune to that public
and brace and then you've got to find
some way else to keep yourself inspired
and excited and interested in,
you know,
um,
that sounds like what he,
what he does,
man.
That's why he's got such varied
interests,
man.
He's such a,
such an interesting dude.
I've got him on my phone right now.
I've got their greatest hits.
I was just listening to them like diver
down to some of those songs running with
the devil.
Oh God.
Damn.
Those were good songs.
Unbelievable.
It just.
But they were so big that it's no wonder
that they broke up.
It's like,
who the fuck knows how to manage that?
Like I was having a conversation with
someone about Justin bieber where
they're like,
you know,
do what he did.
He did this the other day and that
happened the other day.
I'm like,
do you know how fucking crazy I would be
if I was Justin Bieber?
That kid's holding it together.
Rum Markup Markup.
They.
Yeah.
When I was 18 and 19 years old,
if I had $100,000,000
on a fucking Ferrari,
I right now,
Bro,
right now talking to her right now,
I'd be a mess.
Yeah.
I mean the kid's fine.
He's fine.
So he spit on somebody who knows what
happened,
really knows when you're constantly
surrounded by people.
Oh,
he's a nice guy.
He was in the laugh factory.
He was in that pain.
The crowd on a Tuesday night and and
Donna Eric gets onstage and Justin's up
there and he goes,
just,
and it must have been really hard for
you,
but you know,
before you made it,
that one tough year when you were like
14.
Fucking great.
There is also comes up with one liners
like just off the top of his head.
He's an animal.
He's,
he's so fucking legit fucking dumb.
Stand up for 100 years and a high level.
I always love to remind dom that I paid
to see him before I ever did comedy
myself.
Saturday.
Yeah,
I remember his jokes.
I did his job.
Got I paid to see him in Nick's comedy.
Stop.
I actually went two nights in a row
because he missed his flight or
something like that on the first night.
And so that was how I found out about
Denis leary had.
Dennis leary went up that night and I
was like,
who is this guy?
Where the fuck is dominant?
I painted seat down my rarer.
Well,
something happened.
There was like a missed flight or
something along those lines.
So I was like,
God,
this guy who's this guy was like so
bummed out,
but he fucking destroyed.
He destroyed no care,
care for cancer.
I mean this is before I knew anything
about the plagiarism or anything about
the bad things you hear about leary.
All I knew then I didn't even know who
he was,
but he went on and fucking amazing.
He was like my favorite comedian for
like six months.
Incredible.
When you see somebody who's that good at
something you don't stand up for the
first time and you have like maybe
designs on what?
Like I just did this interview just now
today for the San Antonio thing and I
literally said to the guy,
I said,
I still can't believe I can do standup.
I can't believe I'm lucky enough.
I truly lucky enough to go around the
country and make people laugh.
I can't believe I have that capacity.
Like the great surprise of my life was
waking up one day and realizing I think
maybe I can do this if I really
practice.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
when did you,
when did you come to that?
I will always thought you always knew
you could do.
No Man.
No,
I was a silly goose always as you know.
But um,
I remember I a Patty Jenkins,
my old,
my old girlfriend,
the director said,
Brian,
I got,
I made a speech or something at a
wedding or something and I was funny and
she said,
I got three words for you dude.
Stand up comedy.
You're not
going to walk into a room as this guy or
that like,
whoa,
that guy's really unique.
He's five foot 11,
165 pounds with Brown eyes and Brown
hair,
you know,
you're,
you're not going to go in there looking
like you said,
but you're funny.
And she got me to start doing it.
And I was like,
I can't do this.
But I went home and wrote a monologue on
what it's like to be reborn.
A penguin,
a legless flightless bird in the middle
of the South Pole.
And I was like,
that's kind of a funny idea.
Concept.
I don't know.
And I wrote it and I,
I came up to my friends at night and I
said,
hey,
I heard this comic doing these jokes and
I pretended it was somebody else.
And they laughed.
And that's slowly how I built a set.
That's a good way of doing it.
And that's so like your personality to
do that.
You're not really a self congratulatory
God.
Terrible.
That's,
that's what you would do.
You would,
you would congratulate someone else.
Make a pre pretend character.
Oh,
my friend is so funny.
He says,
that's so funny.
I do have so hard.
And I was like,
I think I'm onto something very clever
way to begin standing up,
kind of like to practice on people.
I would do that with some of the,
this common cat guy with that.
I don't know what he looks like.
He had red hair and I do the joke.
This was all before I met you.
Yes.
Yeah.
When I met you,
you were doing comedy a little bit.
You were,
but you had gotten into the door.
And it's,
and I don't blame anybody for this,
but there's,
there's a,
uh,
an attitude that exists or at least it
used to when you got a series or got
some sort of a sitcom stopped when you
could stop doing your stand up.
You know,
I actually had a good friend and a guy I
respect very much said to me,
you know,
who's a producer?
And I was like,
are you talking about like,
what are you,
this is,
I'm just doing this for money like
crazy.
Stand up is the greatest thing in the
world for you to,
you don't know because you've never done
it.
And you know,
and even if you do it and you suck at
it,
if there's a possibility that you can
get good enough to be good at it,
stick with that shit so much fun.
It's way better than the activity.
Also a constant challenge.
Like if you're a Rockstar,
you can sing the same song for 30 years.
The stones can still sing.
Start me up.
And everybody cheers.
You fucking stand up.
You've got to reinvent yourself.
When they come to see you,
they,
they want to see a new bag of tricks,
bro.
Oh yeah.
They're not there to like see your do
your greatest hits.
Yeah.
I put on my special whenever it was a
couple months ago.
I don't remember.
I'm not doing a single bit from that.
That's it.
It's all done.
That shit's dead and burdens what I'm.
All my stuff is no fun to do though,
man.
Because uh,
I,
you know,
I've been inspired by quite a few guys
that do that on a regular basis.
Bill Burr does on a regular basis.
Louis CK does on a regular basis and I
think he got a lot of people thinking
that way.
Like just throw me thinking and come up
with the Nh totally right.
Because what you really want to see is a
lot of different material from
comedians.
It's also keeps you in a really active
stays in line.
Like I've really learned how to write
anywhere no matter what.
And I'm always thinking of new stuff.
So we decided like how hard we can push
ourselves.
Like,
Oh God,
I knew our a year.
I couldn't do it.
Yeah,
you probably could.
You probably could just fucking go to
work and then when you do do it,
like when are coming up with new
stuff.
It's so.
It's so exciting.
It's like the shows have a different
energy to them because you're still
laughing at the shit too.
It's like it's still hitting you like,
and I don't know how you are when you're
creating material,
but when I'm creating a material,
I don't even know where the fuck it's
coming from.
I never feel like it's mine.
I never do it.
It's a beautiful notion that you're a
channel for something that already
exists,
you know?
Well,
I think it's because the only way to
truly use your creativity correctly is
to take your sense of you out of the
equation.
So it's not really that you're tapping
into a muse per se,
as to take you out of the equation,
allows all the creativity to sort of
appear and unfold.
It's you.
This idea of you.
Ego is such an overwhelmingly
constricting mindset.
You know,
and then let me,
let me,
let me piggyback on that before you go
on to this.
I love this.
I love what you're saying.
And,
and,
and when you say ego,
a lot of that for you young people.
Let me get specific and I think a lot of
is we all define ourselves on very
strong lines.
Men especially in this society are told
to define yourself along strong lines.
You know,
I'm,
I'm a fighter,
I'm a tough guy.
You can't push me whatever it might be.
I'm a musician that comes with a lot of
baggage and I think that that one of the
nice things about trying to learning how
to create is to loosen those lines a
little.
Don't try to define yourself,
don't have.
You don't have to be right.
Don't,
don't pigeon hole yourself into a tough
guy or I'm this guy,
right?
No,
not when you're creating.
And it goes back to what you said,
take yourself out of the equation.
Well,
people try to define themselves because
they're insecure.
You know what I mean?
That's how when I was a young man and I
was insecure,
this one I tried to,
I tried to define myself.
I would try to pretend to be somebody I
would try to,
you know,
as much as I wanted to be an individual,
complete individual.
I certainly wasn't good at it,
but,
you know,
at the end it's also like I was just,
I just played volleyball with Brendan
Schaub,
mayhem,
Miller and uh,
my buddy Kiran all fighters and,
you know,
obviously,
and I'm sitting there looking at the
fucking,
like,
just,
you know,
Jason's been fighting for 15 years,
retired now,
but he's still a fucking rough athletic,
big guide.
I'm looking at fucking shop.
Should have a statue.
I should have a statue built to him that
I can just,
you know.
And,
and,
um,
you're looking at what the fuck are you
talking?
I'm gay.
I'm straight.
I just want to talk about Brendan.
I get very good.
No,
but I'm looking at how big and strong
these guys.
And I thought to myself,
there's always somebody stronger.
There's always somebody stronger than
those guys.
And,
and by the way,
no,
that's not true.
There's going to be one strongest guy.
It's gotta be it's gotta be this and
that.
It's not a,
there's always gonna be someone brings
me to my point,
which is the idea that,
you know,
there,
there's not a real difference in some
ways between me and sharp or somebody
who's really big in the sense that yes,
they're stronger,
but we're all compared to somebody else.
We're all kind of like,
depending on what context you're
standing in,
I'm stronger than this guy over here.
He's stronger than me.
You really think about this shit.
Yeah.
Why?
Well,
I was just thinking about how we,
we,
we kind of,
I was thinking about how we try to kind
of aim for certain things,
but you're 45,
seven as an example.
I'm just using an example of anything
you do.
Like if you're a musician you want to
play like that guy.
I'm just saying that it,
the,
the only thing that matters is that as a
false,
that is a false way of going about
things.
All you can do is control your own
expression and who you are.
That's all you can do is go.
There is no the idea of a comparing to
something bigger or something that is an
illusion almost.
It's the only thing you can do is get
it.
Try to not dilute who you are.
You want to keep it as.
Because it's so hard to say.
Saying that and doing that.
It's like,
what is he saying?
So what does he mean?
You know?
It's just,
you got to know that your ego will fuck
you up your ego even though you feel
like it's part of you and you feel like
it's good to have it protect you,
so you're bullshit yourself about
things.
It's super important to know when you
fuck up and not be in denial because
when you're in denial,
it sets you back because no one's
perfect.
I'm not perfect.
You're not perfect.
There's not a single perfect human
being.
The idea is ridiculous because it's like
you don't.
You're a different person depending on
when I catch you,
you're a different person depending on
what time of the day and you know and
what,
what happened to you recently or you
know,
what bad thing has gone down in your
life.
You're a different person in every
minute of every day,
300,
65 days in a way like,
you know,
trying to,
trying to say,
this is who I am.
I'm a tough guy or on this.
You've got to just learn from mistakes.
Always of course have the ethic of,
you know,
just trying to be a good person who's
trying to be nice.
Try not to.
Yeah,
but.
Well let me ask you this.
Like you were saying,
and I was thinking about this the other
day,
you know,
nobody's perfect.
You can try to strive for perfection.
It's kind of a good thing.
You don't ever reach it,
but the idea is you can imagine what
perfection isn't a way.
Like you ever feel that way.
You ever feel like,
you know,
like you're doing this thing which is
stand up and you keep putting out stuff
in your mind's eye.
You have a notion of what,
what the perfect.
I don't.
I think that's all waste.
This is what I do.
What I want or what I would try to do.
I just try to keep writing funny shit.
Just bright it,
make it funny,
put it together as well as I know,
you know,
I explained this to Ra once,
but it's applicable to me to,
you know,
Ari and I were talking about comedy and
like what's going on now that he has
like real fans and this,
this,
this new obligation.
And I said,
you know,
if I go,
I'm an Ra,
shift your fan.
I go,
I think you're really hilarious.
So if I was,
you know,
take me out of the context of being a
professional stand up comedian.
If I,
if I was a guy just to doing something
else,
you're laughing and I found out about
Ari,
I'd be like,
Oh,
this guy is funny.
I would want to buy his CD.
I would want to buy his DVD.
I would become an arch for your fan.
I go,
but once that happens,
you're the only guy who can give me Ari.
Fear you're the only guy who can produce
that material,
like you have this weird
obligation and if you do something like
this,
comics that were like really big at one
point in time and they sort of stopped
delivering comedy,
they stopped making,
making new specials and people sort of
gave up on them because they don't
really talk about them that much anymore
because they're not getting material
from them on a regular basis.
You know?
So you're the only Brian callen you're
the only guy you're trying to reach
Brian Cowen fans.
So I just try to.
I know that people think that the
ridiculous shit that I do is funding and
I know how to do the ridiculous should I
do so just keep doing it.
That's my thing.
Yeah.
The idea that the.
I guess the idea of perfection is really
a static notion and you're never static
as a verb.
I always,
yeah,
always trying to update the bits.
It's a little bit different.
Every show there's always something new
I'm adding,
I'm taking away.
I approaching it a different way.
I'm,
I'm fucking with it.
I'm trying to find out how to do it the
right way and I'll learn along the way
through trial and error and from my own
feelings of being too verbose or too
clunky or whatever the fuck it is.
And so in that way,
and doing it like that,
like you're never in the equation
equation the equation.
The equation is always the impact of the
material,
how,
what is the best way I can do to make
this funny,
like,
what is if I was,
you know,
if I'm experiencing this myself,
like,
what is the best way to do it?
So you sort of become a passenger,
you know,
it's like you're the one who has to sort
of orchestrate it.
But,
you know,
the concept of the Muse,
I hate when I say,
you know,
that many times the concept of the muse
that's,
that's a,
uh,
fakers um,
you know,
I really should be like,
oh,
I'm,
I'm like,
no,
you don't know anything.
You didn't know what the fuck are you
even talking about right now.
But I,
I feel like it's,
um,
the more you can take yourself out of
it,
the more you can say,
I just want to be the best I can be.
I want to be perfect.
I want to be all that shit is like,
that guy's not doing any comedy.
That's that one.
Who needs all that?
That's an annoying,
that ego thing.
That's the creepy part of you that you
don't want to feed.
You want that to shrivel up.
You want that to shrivel up like a
witch's tit.
Because I remember that there was a
lawrence,
Olivia was a famous actor and he'd done
this production of,
uh,
you know,
of Othello or something like that.
And he was amazing and everybody came
back and said was the most incredible
performance and he wasn't really black,
dark mood.
And I said,
well,
what's the matter?
He goes,
he said,
the greatest performance we've anybody's
ever seen.
And he said,
I know,
I just have no idea how to repeat it,
you know?
And,
and his thinking was wrong.
I sense there,
you know,
you just got to go to.
Then you got to go zen,
you gotta go Zan and understand that if
you can do that,
that means you could do that.
It doesn't mean you're going to do it
every night.
I mean,
there's going to be nice,
like there's times when I'm talking on
this podcast where every third or fourth
fucking word is my fat.
Stupid tongue is hitting my teeth wrong.
Excuse me.
I mean marijuana and it's not even that.
It's not.
It's not that I'm London Pretty Dapper,
just not.
What am I trying to say is like there's.
There's ebbs and flows to things.
There's never a perfect absolute
sustainable rhythm for anything.
So you,
if you,
if Lawrence Olivier can crush it like
that,
what that means is that he can crush it.
Like that doesn't mean you're gonna
crush it like that every night,
but he crushed it like that lie and it's
alive when things are live,
it's a different experience.
Do you remember in the book of five
rings with me on the fast,
she says,
practice something enough so that the
thing of itself reveals itself.
The spirit reveals that.
What do you think he meant by that?
Well,
because the same thing he meant that
you,
if you know the way broadly,
you can see it in all things and that's
the same thing.
It's like the way is the spirit of a
thing is really excellence.
Whether it's bowling or golf or archery
or the spirit of a thing is excellence.
The spirit of a thing is finding how to
control the body and to get it all
online or how would you run up and do
that?
Perfect.
Three point.
Oh,
or three point foul shot.
Did you ever see that film,
that video of that autistic kid that
never played basketball before and they
threw him in on the last game to Brian,
find this on my twitter.
This is incredible shit.
Matt.
Incredible,
incredible shit.
This kid,
it's kind of unrelated,
but this kid has a high functioning
autistic and they put him in on this a
basketball game and he's like,
you could tell that the kids like loved
by all these teammates and when they
take this kid and they finally let him
play in the game.
So they're one of the last games.
The kid gets up,
the place goes nuts.
They love him,
they're cheering for him.
He throws his first ball and it's a Mrs.
by like six feet and they're like,
oh Jesus Christ.
And then he can't miss.
He's nailing three pointers from the
outside and the crowd is going fucking
crazy.
This kid misses one shot and then gets
in this insane groove of over and over
and over again,
slamming three pointers.
He won like the school record.
See Mrs.
That's,
that's not it.
There's A.
Yeah,
that's one of them.
Yeah.
But Jay Mac wasn't done.
He kept shooting and kept hitting
another person.
Oh,
did you start this like inside of it?
A little bit.
Okay.
Yeah.
The beginning.
They show the first basket with which he
misses by like six feet and then they
went crazy.
Look at them,
run on the field,
grab them and picking them up and
carrying them around their shoulders.
Imagine how good that kid must've felt.
Man.
Athletic director.
If I retired today,
this would be the one thing that I
talked about forever.
Wow.
Dude,
are you kidding me?
Going amazing.
Yes.
That's another word for excellence.
I think as you,
as you speak about it as harmony,
everything moving in the way it's
supposed to,
that that's what it sounds like you were
talking about that,
that that's a form that's kind of like
hard
harmonizing with a frequency man,
like getting into something and a and a
pattern and where everything is.
Everything is firing the way it should.
Yeah,
and and understanding what it,
what it really is like the more like in
Musashi talking about it's totally
applicable to standup comedy because in
talking about like the more time you
practice it in,
the more you observe it in,
the more you understand it,
the more it's what it is reveals itself
to you and then you know how to operate
and try to achieve excellence within it.
That's ever it is.
You're almost writing it.
You're almost,
it's,
it's doing the work.
Yeah.
That's why I think that activities are
really important for people.
There's a lot of people that
unfortunately don't engage in activity.
They don't engage and don't have hobbies
or anything like that.
I learn a language or do something.
Do something that's exciting art of
learning.
You know the problem with our education
system,
Gore Vidal was saying this,
is that what it was,
that we don't have an education system
that teaches you how to think.
We don't play so true.
And that's,
that's,
that's the,
there is an art to learning,
man.
There's an art to learning.
There's an art
art to be in a human beings,
right?
It really is.
And no one teaches us.
We don't know what the fuck we're doing.
We're all idiots raising other people,
bar with the same flaws that we were
raised with.
There's no manual for it.
Exactly.
And there's,
when you look at what we consider our,
our,
our source of education as far as like
what is distributed to us nightly,
what's the news?
Right?
I mean that's really the education that
people have today.
Once you get out of school,
unless you're reading books on your own,
where are you getting your information
about the world?
You're getting it from the fucking news.
The news doesn't really represent what's
a going on in the world,
and B,
it doesn't say anything about how you
should be dealing with this,
how you should be thinking,
how we,
how we should resolve these issues.
It's like this tattle tale that just
goes running over and tells us about all
the fucked up shit that's happening in
the world,
but they don't.
It's not a dialogue with a person.
It's like a source of information
shy.
The way that that complaint goes back at
least 3,500
years.
Socrates,
when he was in his trial said,
you take a,
you wouldn't take a horse to try to ride
it and not train it.
The same applies to a human being.
You got to,
you got to start with,
with the notion of he was trying to
teach philosophy in the sense that you
better,
you better know what questions to ask
throughout your life.
And we should start with young people,
educate young people the right way with
the right questions.
If you don't do that,
then,
then you know,
you've got to start with a base almost,
you know.
And,
and,
uh,
we don't,
we don't do that.
Men were,
it's almost like learning Jujitsu,
just learning moves without learning the
principles behind it
first.
Yeah.
Well it's also like learning Jujitsu
without going over the real correct
drills,
learning real life applications and,
and the,
you know,
the way school is set up,
I,
you know,
again,
you motherfucker,
the way school is set up,
it's,
they have x amount of thousand kids and
they have to get these kids through with
a basic understanding of the building
blocks of our world.
They have to understand that they have
done understanding how to structure a
sentence and they understand they have
to understand form paragraphs and they
had got to know what happened in the
past and then you're off on your own.
Good luck fucker.
Stopped College.
Yeah.
You talk about taking yourself out of
the equation.
That's an Asian thing more than a
western thing.
Certainly more than American.
You know,
if they had Chinese people look at a
fish tank and then they had Americans
look at the fish tank,
the Americans,
uh,
describe the fish.
The Chinese described how the
relationship between the rocks,
the seaweed,
the fish,
the boat in there and everything they
were,
they were looking at the entire,
the entire picture and that,
that's a lot of it is.
Um,
but it was a paramedic in a medic,
I'm sorry,
in Vietnam for two terms,
two tours.
And one of the things he found was that
the Viet Cong,
when they get injured,
they wouldn't go into shock.
And you could,
you can interrogate them.
They wouldn't go into shock.
The Americans get it in.
A lot of times they go into shock.
It's very dangerous when you go into
shock,
which is actually,
you know what shock is
the lock.
Yeah.
But you're trying to flush
blood from your extremities and go right
to where the wound is.
Like sort of like the core area and your
body can shut down.
It's very dangerous.
And that is from panic.
That's right.
That's from your,
your,
your heart races.
And instead of slowing down.
And so why?
Well,
one of the things was that when an
American would get shot,
you'd go,
Holy Shit,
I've been shot.
And you focus on that wound.
When Viet Cong would get shot,
they were taught.
Now the whole culture wasn't about you.
You were a leaf on a very big tree.
Put your attention out there.
And,
and that was kind of one of the things
he took back from Vietnam because
somebody said to him,
you know,
you've been teaching this acting class
from seven to 12 for five years.
I've never seen you yawn once,
not once.
And he says,
I don't think about,
I don't,
I don't think about myself.
I'm never part of this equation,
man.
I learned a long time ago.
Even if I'm tired,
it's just a form of energy.
And I spent a lot of time.
If I start worrying about being tired,
I'll get tired.
He's got he,
he was 55 and he just was very good at
taking themselves completely out of the.
Yeah.
I think that the,
you can definitely trip yourself up,
but some bad behavior patterns as far as
your,
your feeling in your health and the
negativity that you see in the
environment all over the place.
I mean,
we've all been around that one person
that just complains about everything.
Like,
oh great,
look at the hotel we're staying at.
Oh fuck.
Look at this fucking place.
Oh Jesus,
great.
This place hasn't been updated since the
70 [inaudible] like,
will you shut the fuck up man?
There's a guy who,
who um,
I don't want to speak out of turn.
I don't know if his name,
but he's a writer,
tried to kill himself and he was
listening to birds and some girl was
there and she was talking to him and she
said,
listen to the birds.
He goes,
what are you here?
He said,
I don't,
I don't like listening to bird.
She said,
why?
She goes,
because they're so beautifully says you
hear.
But I hear a bunch of animals trying to
fight for territory and scratch out and
yelling at each other.
And she went,
hey dude,
don't ruin birds for me man.
Maybe smart as fuck you.
I don't want to be.
You're kind of smart,
you know?
And it really is a question of what you
choose to look at,
what you choose to hear.
Well,
how emotionally invested
you choose to be in whether these birds
fight to the death.
I'll see your belief system,
right?
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
You,
you,
you can change your belief system in
some ways.
Choosing whether or not you're going to
be affected by all this information.
You know,
what I was going to say is that the,
when we were talking about the,
uh,
needing some sort of a,
a lesson in how to think and how to
operate the mind.
If the human mind,
if the human body was the just,
you know,
just the human experience.
If that wasn't an instrument that you
had to learn to use,
think about navigating the human life
with the human body and language and
think about if you came from somewhere
else and the human body wasn't in the
human experience,
wasn't just a person living a life but
rather was a ride that you had to figure
out how to,
how to master,
how to accomplish and that the human
animal with its creative abilities with
disabilities or reach out to people with
its,
uh,
ability to build buildings and use
electricity.
And all these different things,
that's a.
that's a,
that's a vehicle.
That's what that is.
Learn it,
learn how to use that vehicle.
You would have intensive study for a lot
of just trying to figure out how to go
about the correct way of doing this.
They would be like,
you know,
you.
You'd have to figure out what is the
best way to think is the best way.
Well,
most beneficial way to you to approach
every project as a,
as a person moving around in this human
world with this human machine,
it would be like a super complicated
thing,
but instead it's just two people.
Fucking some guy shoots a load in the
girl,
she swells up blank.
A person comes out,
no one knows shit.
Sound effects by the way.
Thank you.
So the three of them are standing there.
No one knows what the fuck is going on.
And they keep doing the same thing.
They keep interacting with each other.
Same thing,
the way the human,
the way the human being and the human
body interacts with the world is so
bizarre and complicated and to get it
right and correct.
Take so much fucking thinking.
It's a mandate saying Hudl.
It,
we just let these things just go loose
out into the world,
you know what I mean?
Which is why people are desperate and
lonely and all that.
We're caught in this machine.
There's a real machine going on with
society today and that machine is,
uh,
the building of society,
the increasing of bandwidth,
you know,
the interconnectivity that's provided by
technology.
It's all of that and it's all of that
with this exponentially increasing
momentum behind it.
And we're all caught up in that and
we're caught up in that and we have
mortgages and we have bills and we have
all these,
but we're,
we're,
we're doing is,
we're feeding this system.
We're feeding the system of televisions
and computers and cell phones and new
clothes and distracting.
It's so distracting.
Like you,
you,
you start unknowledgeable and,
and the Greeks who I said you go from
knowledge but you don't jump all the way
to wisdom.
There's an in between place,
which is correct.
Opinion correct.
Opinion comes from when you study,
as you're reaching for wisdom,
you start to develop.
The world crystallizes around you with
the right teaching and and stuff.
You start to learn what the what,
what sort of the correct way to look at
and reach and follow the correct opinion
is,
and then you finally get to a point
where you understand and can explain why
that is the correct opinion.
That takes a long fucking time.
That's life mastery in a way,
but it's like what you're saying is
it's,
it's we don't have a system and we tried
it with public education,
but we don't have a way or a system to
really teach people how to live the art.
No,
no one knows what the fuck they're doing
and we the,
the people that were raised by,
they didn't know what the fuck they're
doing either.
I mean,
my parents are very nice people.
My mother is a with my step dad.
They've been together forever.
It's like they're very nice couple.
They're very nice people,
but they were raised by people,
didn't know shit,
and their parents were raised by people
who didn't know shit and this era that
we're living in right now,
it's like human beings are just starting
to wake up and realize that we were all
living in this weird sort of momentous
world.
His world that moves on momentum and
momentum doesn't make any sense at all
and we're all just waking up realizing
that it was set up by people didn't know
what the fuck they were doing.
I mean they knew how to build buildings
and knew how to use electricity,
but no one knew how to teach society how
to chill the fuck out,
relax and enjoy each other.
Not One fucking person besides like
Martin Luther King and a few people with
some dreamy speeches.
Not One person emphasizes that in the
role of government.
Not One person is pushing that like
can't we figure out a way that human
beings are just nicer to each other?
Can't we figure out a way where there's
maybe a little bit less profit,
but also less pollution and less fucking
with people and less light,
less control over the human population?
I would say that you're also dealing
with the residue of of a most of human
history.
Almost all of it has been not enough to
eat.
Yeah,
and dying.
Yeah.
No,
it's no doubt.
There's been a lot of things that led us
to this point.
This is also the first point.
We have a responsibility as the human
beings that have the first access to
this sort of information to not be
looked at like a bunch of silly Fox by
the people of the future because that's
a real problem because if I look back,
I've been living this life right now.
Just looking at all that silly nonsense
that human beings are involved with.
Like everybody.
I looked on twitter and everybody has
these fucking equal signs on their
twitter Avatar to let every one know
that they're into marriage equality,
equality.
It's marriage equality.
You
should be.
You should be.
That's like saying you're having that on
your twitter Avatar.
You might as well just say water's wet
is hot,
hot.
It's cold,
cold.
I didn't.
Of course marriage equality makes sense.
The fact that you even have to to.
Who are you talking to who does this?
But seriously in 2000 and fucking 13,
anybody we should find out who doesn't
have that on their avatar.
It should be that.
Let's.
How about nobody use her face anymore
and,
and let's,
let's find out and do the people who
have a problem with it.
It gives a shit whether or not a couple
of lesbians want to marry each other.
You're an asshole.
And maybe nobody tells you you're an
asshole.
Why do you give a fuck about them?
You worrying at all about what other
people are doing?
Sucks.
It sucks for everyone around you.
You fuck everything up.
You care that two people love each other
and they want to sign some paperwork.
Why do you give a fuck?
What do you give a fuck of?
She signed some paperwork that the other
chicks going to be your ass eating slave
till the end of time and she'll have to
be reincarnated in the future ass eater
and upon turning 18 will resume her
practice.
Whereas is this going to be immortal
right then on paper with what fucking
difference does it make?
Why do you care if you care?
You're an asshole.
You're just an ass or understood it.
I never understood that.
It's fucking dumb.
The desire to control the people and
when pose your mythology or your belief
system on someone else,
it's really uncreative fucks to are not
thinking about how ridiculous you're
going to look in the future when they're
looking back on the past,
the way they looked at those idiots that
thought that leaches were the best way
to cure your broken leg.
Those fucking people.
We laugh at them today and don't tell me
about scientific applications of
leeches.
Yeah,
fucks because there's none of that is
people like,
you know,
there are medical applications for
leeches.
Like people sent me that because I was
making fun for gangrene.
Hey,
you can use it for stuff,
but guess what?
Medicine works better for almost every
maggots.
For Nuggets.
Yeah.
Maggots.
Sorry.
I think digitally just for something to
like to coagulate blood or some shit
with maggots will eat all the
[inaudible] tissue.
Right?
What they,
uh,
they'll clean up dead and they think
stop infections.
It's really kind of crazy for you.
The maggots eating your flesh is good.
Put a cast on you.
They throw a bunch of maggots down there
and because they can't eat you,
they can only eat the stuff that's
fucked up.
I mean they're not really like good
eaters,
so like it pays to have them all mushed
up and your moons and actually
apparently they're good eating if you
need to either a high source of protein.
That shit.
What's insearch?
It isn't as interesting how we have
this,
like really these really clear views
about what is and isn't good food or
something that you should eat.
And crabs and crabs and spiders.
Could there be an animal that's closer
to looking like each other in the same
family?
Yeah.
They're in the same family.
Found out that lobsters were in the lice
family.
I couldn't eat lobsters anymore.
I was like,
what do you mean in the lice family
dudes in the jungle that they cook up
the trenches.
No,
he never seen them.
They look yummy.
It looks like a soft shell crab.
I bet.
I bet they taste good.
They're all in the same family,
but we have this weird thing,
right?
Like when we're talking about maggots,
like if it wasn't like,
look,
what is hemp force protein?
It's fucking ground up plants.
Mushy ground up plans.
Like,
okay,
you eat plants.
Got It.
Okay.
What is.
What are maggots?
Maggots are just these little fleshy.
Okay,
well what?
What?
What do you eat?
Tell me what you do.
What are you cool with?
You?
Cool with yogurt.
Eat the flesh off an animal and cool
with yogurt.
You know what that is?
You know you're eating like a fucking
civilization.
You know you're eating the living
organism or eating acidophilus.
A pure living organisms.
Bacteria.
What are you doing?
Stupid.
Do you know what you're doing?
But you're like,
new maggots are bad.
Mcateer little buddies that your little
wound cleaning buddies,
they're full of protein and you're
saying no to them,
but yet you're just chugging down that
fucking corn fed beef.
These fatty,
diseased cows,
fat,
sloppy heart pounding as they pumps
blood through fucking caked up arteries,
slivers living in no shit.
Oh my God.
Just to fucking amount of fat that you
get on.
But that's the only way you get a
delicious Ribeye.
The kind that you really.
Oh,
you cook it over a little salt and
pepper.
Don't get crazy.
All you need is a little salt and
pepper.
The,
uh,
grass fed beef though.
Once you get used to that.
It's a.
to me it's,
I feel so much better eating.
Maybe it's psychological,
the oils,
first of all,
the room.
And it's.
So cows are supposed to eat grass.
It would.
They're definitely,
you're eating a healthier and for sure
it tastes more like a game.
And also the,
the oils in the meat are very different
when they grasp the oils.
The fatty acids are,
are,
I believe,
I can't remember what the ratio is,
what it is,
but the fatty acids literally changed
from like Omega three to Omega six or
something like that.
I mean,
so,
so when you eat at a bison or you eat
grass fed beef,
the oils are healthier and,
and a lot of,
um,
heart doctors on Dr Oz are prescribing
grassfed beef because it helps with
inflammation.
It actually brings inflammation in the
body down according to a lot of
research.
That's really interesting because I
talked to a woman who was a
chiropractor.
We were talking about desks,
you know,
because I got a disc issue on my back
and she said,
besides this thing called the mackenzie
protocol,
it's like a series of stretches that
they use to elongate the spine.
She said changing the Diet is very
important.
And uh,
she recommended a bunch of different uh,
anti-inflammatories and cutting out all
week.
Yeah.
That that,
that,
believe it or not,
like people who are eating gluten and
like that,
the more and more people are sort of
understanding that what you're doing is
just slowly poisoning yourself with that
stuff,
but you can
handle it.
That's really what's going on.
And when you cut it out you're like,
oh whoa.
Yeah.
Why don't feel so good now?
Like,
what's going on?
Like that stuff's not good for you.
I stopped eating bread and also because
it's got a high glycemic index,
it's Kinda like spikes your insulin.
So I eat brown rice and yams and I just
feel better when I do that.
I do that,
but yet I don't.
I'm not rigid.
I still will go to a nice restaurant and
have locked bread with olive oil and
balsamic vinegar and all the way this is
salience do.
And they lived to 105.
I wonder how much bread they they eat.
Do they eat a lot of bread?
You know when you go there,
you see the bread they eat.
It is,
it is as healthy.
It's a meal in itself too.
It's like you see the bread up in like,
oh,
you got to northern Italy.
I went to this place.
I walked into this bread place that
bread is,
it doesn't look like bread.
Okay.
It looks like God just like a block of
seeds and nuts and you're like,
what the fuck are you could hit somebody
in the head and they die.
My grandfather used to.
My,
my grandfather came over here during the
depression on a,
on a boat.
They,
his family hopped in a boat from Italy
and came up with a fun ride by the way.
And they lived in this like seriously
Italian neighborhood in New Jersey.
And we used to,
uh,
it was almost dead by the time I got
older.
But when I lived with them for a bit,
when I first moved to New York when I
was 23,
I guess 23 or 24.
I live with my grandfather for like a
year and he would still go by his bread
from this place in New Jersey.
And there's some people that had been
there from the 19 fifties.
They had been selling bread.
And this one,
probably even more,
I think it was actually the thirties
they were there.
Real Shit.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It was just old school bread place and
they would go and get the bread every
day.
And that's how the immigrants like
dropbox,
by the way,
everything was homemade tomato sauce.
My grandmother was always like cooking
things and it was always homemade.
She,
they grew their own tomatoes.
They turned them into tomato sauce that
made their own pasta.
My grandmother would be like rolling
Pasta and nothing came out of screaming
at my grandfather.
Get off me,
Joe,
you leave me alone.
I'm tired of your bullshit.
I'm going to tell you right now.
I'm going to move in with my sister.
You feel like,
oh,
they would go crazy.
My grandparents were Sicilian and so it
was the same thing.
Nothing came out of a can.
My grandfather's fucking.
Well,
they didn't have kids to know.
It's like the idea of paying for
something which costs more when you can
grow in your backyard.
Like what?
Are you stupid?
My grandfather would show up with the
wheel of Parmesan or we'll sit.
We had a food pantry and it would sit in
this big closet like food pantry,
like it was do you could walk into it,
you know,
there's a real issue with with the
cheese in this country and milk in that
people want everything to be pasteurized
and homogenized and that raw milk when
it's from an excellent source,
should be available to you,
just like raw eggs are available to you,
just like raw meat and it should be
clear and obvious as to whether or not
you're eating bad food.
Like when you're eating a steak.
Okay?
And if you buy a stake and the stake
sits in the refrigerator for like five
or six days,
you don't
get to it,
it starts to get a little funky.
You know?
You know why that's because it's a
fucking thing from an animal and it's
used to be alive.
It's decaying and that Shit's real.
And as soon as you stop that process,
okay,
as soon as you step in,
you're monkeying around with nature.
Okay?
And I know,
I know.
It's good.
I know it's helped a lot of people get
through some really dark times in this
world.
We're milk because it was homogenized
and pasteurized.
They could keep it longer and it fed
people sure,
but at a certain point in time,
we have to realize that all that
homogenization and pasteurization is not
the healthy way to do it.
The healthy way to do it is to eat it
fresh like it.
They like the healthy way to do anything
and then it becomes this industry with
taking this milk and changing it through
this process of homogenization and
pasteurization.
Well,
what happens to those people?
What if you don't have to homogenize the
pasteurized milk and what will be out of
business?
Listen,
Charlie,
I've been given you a lot of money all
these years.
I've supported you for governor and 84 I
support to you again.
We've got to make raw milk Hillier so
they illegal firearms,
safety.
They arrest people for selling Rondo.
You can't get raw cheese.
Raw Cheese is super fucking hard to get
man because they want you to use
homogenized and pasteurized milk because
if it's just some joe blow farmer who
has no access to homogenization
pasteurization,
just start selling his milk and people
actually like it.
What the fucking world could end.
That's my problem.
And and that's,
that's where,
that's why the only thing we should all
be talking about is campaign finance
reform.
The idea that money in politics,
as long as there's money in politics,
you're going to have very powerful
wealthy interests controlling even what
the fuck you eat.
Well.
Yeah,
and I think it's not a bad option.
This is what I want to say because if
you are in a low income household and
you're in a situation where when you buy
a gallon of milk,
like that gallon of milk needs to all be
used,
it goes the pasteurized milk and if,
if you,
you know,
if it lasts for a week and a half with
pasteurization,
but it only lasts three days and it's
raw,
that fucks your family.
I'm sure.
And I completely understand that.
So what we have to look at then,
if you were looking at a holistic
approach,
is how do we eliminate that from
civilized society?
How do we eliminate people that are
working in such poverty that they're
worried about their milk being bad?
If it goes three days like milk,
how much milk costs?
Like what does milk,
like four bucks or something like that.
For a lot of people that's a deal
breaker.
Look,
they're,
they're really trying to put it all
together.
That's kind of fucked up.
That's kind of crazy that,
you know,
some guy could be working in a job all
day every day and then they take taxes
out of that and then when you look at
it,
he still doesn't have enough money to
eat natural food.
That's where the food stamps program
comes from.
That's all those things.
All those answers,
that's not the answer,
right?
The answer is sort of a restructuring of
how much your time is worth.
Like what is in figuring out also how to
fund some way.
I mean it's the,
the,
the society we live in is really sort of
like a really nutty game,
you know,
finding your spot in that game and
finding had six points from that game
where you just said is finding your
spots because the dea,
as technology grows exponentially and
our economy will start to change
exponentially.
There isn't.
You've got to figure out how to make
yourself useful and traditional labor
and things is not going to be worth and
stand already is this case is not going
to be worth what it was when a robot can
do it and stuff.
So then then where does,
where does a human being,
where are you?
What is your skill set?
Have to be.
My guess is you're going to have to
constantly be taking classes and
constantly be changing and constantly be
keeping up with a,
with an economy that is always moving at
the speed of life.
You know,
I mean it's,
it's moving very quickly.
Speed of life.
That's a funny thing to say,
the speed of life and that's really what
it is.
Like this beautiful life is constantly
ever changing.
And to think that somehow or another
you're obligated to,
to have a job.
I've been a cobbler.
My family were cobblers.
What's going on?
I can't make shoes anymore.
Change.
I can't change what?
Either that or make some shoes that are
undeniably dope.
Everybody wants to go to your shoe store
and buy your handmade shoes because
they're so fucking bad ass.
But unless you attain that sort of
perfection at your craft,
you're not gonna attract people.
You know,
you,
you're going to have to find something
that like.
Imagine if you were like really into
owning a record store and you're like,
man,
I look.
Everybody needs records.
Okay,
I'll tell you,
man,
record store is always going to be
around.
It's a great investment.
I'm going to take my money and I put it
in her records because.
So let's talk about this.
Economists always talk about how things
become obsolete and there's always got
to be there.
The,
the economy.
A capitalist economy is based on the
notion that here's how they do it and
I'm going to come along and do it better
for a premium.
I'll come up with a better way to do
what you're doing and that's the idea.
You know,
the,
you always got a better car for you,
you know,
your car is breaking down.
I got a better car,
you know,
I'll fix that problem for you.
Will sort of be.
I mean,
we are always constantly improving
things and that's one of the more
fascinating things about the human
condition to me.
You know,
I loved that.
I got the apple retina laptop thing.
Look skinny,
tiny and light.
I love that.
I love and you don't need any more
computer than that.
It's not like I can,
I can follow,
but you're so wrong.
I do.
If they come up with a new one,
it's saying that,
you know,
it's not a huge difference.
I want,
once you get that,
it's all unique.
It's very easy now to get everything you
need as far as like a visual experience
or you know,
or just access to information I think to
try to deny or slow down the idea that
we're going to continue to pump out
newer,
greater crazier shit and that you're
going to continue to want it lustfully.
It's ridiculous at this point.
You know,
it's fucking ridiculous.
It's just,
it's a part of what humans are and your
attraction to it is just like your
attraction to tits.
It doesn't make a whole lot of sense,
especially if you know you're never
going to be able to touch them,
but a girl was great.
Tits can walk into a room and you just
go,
oh,
the whole fucking good kid.
He just looked at him this round or they
move when she moves and every girl in
the room was pissed because she's not
wearing a bra.
Oh,
that fucking bitch.
I can't believe she's not wearing a bra.
What a fucking whore.
All my God.
I can't believe she's not wearing a bra.
She shows up in life I can think,
and she's not even wearing a bra,
this fucking pig.
She shows up her tits or Pocan.
Ask Dick in the room,
otherwise known as many women.
I remember when I was with a bunch of
girls,
I was like,
I don't know,
long time ago,
and then this girl comes in and she had
eyeliner on and she had like.
She'd drawn a line around her lips.
She had this.
She was like really kind of.
She had high heels and all the girls
were like,
oh,
look at how gross she is.
She's just so fucking trashy.
And I was like,
that's what I call 1000 percent.
This guy's type.
You fucking fucking boring white chicks
from Connecticut with your flat shoes
and your shitty genes goes,
holds those hot girls.
Does it ever hold the ridicule them?
Do you think they're a bad part of
society?
When women see girls dressing slutty or
flirty,
they fucking hate Boston Irish checks
check.
Whereas nice heels,
you fucking hookah.
Does your mother know you're out there
sucking cock for nickels?
Exactly.
That's attractive hunting.
I think I'll pay you and not the fucking
Italian princess over there.
I'll hold her back.
Oh God.
Where they're painted toes and her that
her fucking skimpy skirt.
They hate hate haters.
God Sad.
It's just a lot of haters out there,
man.
That's a sad thing that women can't
express themselves the way they want
away though.
Like I,
if I,
if I didn't have outlets,
like,
uh,
what do you mean?
You know,
like if you,
if you're just a dude and there was some
guy who shows up,
like fucking shop shows up like with his
shirt off and the girls are all like,
I want to have sex with that guy.
And even your wife is like,
I love that guy.
You're right about that.
That's bullshit.
When dudes bring,
when dudes bring their wife over at me
sometimes and they'll say something
like,
you know,
you,
you're the one on New York on the list.
She's loaded.
What are you talking about?
Stupid.
Like why are you in accepting that from
her?
You know,
why?
Why don't you let anybody.
And these guys were like,
look,
shut the fuck up.
If your wife says,
oh,
I think British chops hot,
she's an asshole.
Right?
Right.
If you're married to some chicken,
she does that.
Just like you're a douchebag.
If you make her feel like that.
If you do that on purpose,
that's.
That's what I'm just saying.
Tish beheaded.
That is a guy.
You have outlets.
It doesn't matter.
A lot of guys are better looking.
I just go,
yeah,
I'll make you laugh.
So fuck you.
Have you liked me anyway because you
have a reoccurring theme.
You have a reoccurring theme.
We're accepting.
You're like,
look,
I'm not this.
I'm not that.
I'm not that,
but under this.
No.
That's a reoccurring thing like it is.
It is very self defining.
You know?
I've been been writing script about
that.
Yeah,
but I got to speak about that shit.
Go.
No Way.
Started Paul Riser.
Yes,
he is.
Paul Pfizer and Paul and no disrespect
to Paul Riser.
I just,
I loved him and aliens.
That was his greatest movie ever
auditioned for Paul Riser once you ever
see him in aliens.
Wasn't a funny role at all.
It was like a really creepy guy role and
you fucking nailed it.
Is acting was so believable,
man.
Fucking.
He played a real creep man and he did an
awesome job.
That's,
that's a great role.
I was amazed that he never did more
serious roles because he was so good in
that.
I mean maybe he didn't enjoy it,
you know?
I mean he,
he was in one of the greatest horror
movies of all time.
I mean,
why not just cut your losses,
but he went and did like a lot of
comedies,
but he was awesome.
Just made so much money on mad about
you.
I think you make $50,
million dollars.
We had some cameramen that said Helen
Hunt was mean.
I've heard that people get sick.
They get.
She probably wanted to be in theater or
perhaps film won an Oscar.
I say.
I've actually had a couple of
conversations with.
Very cool.
Yeah.
You never know.
She didn't want to be on that Shitty
Sitcom that I understand.
It is torture.
Sixth Year.
Yeah.
And I would.
I do not.
I mean,
I,
I am absolutely not saying,
oh poor them.
To you folks out there and go,
hey,
I'll take that fucking job at a
heartbeat and I know you would,
and you're right in saying that,
and yes it is a good job,
but there's something about doing a
really bad show that his soul stealing.
Weird.
I've only been involved in one bad
sitcom ever done some pilots that were
so bad that I was hiding in my dressing
room because I need good,
funny people around.
If I'm doing a TV show can be shitty.
If I liked the people around me,
I'll bear with it for a long time
because the acting gets in the way.
I'm just fucking around all day.
I take one pilots.
I probably did.
I did like one one big pilot.
It was an interesting one for this thing
called overseas.
Oh yeah,
I remember that.
I remember you got that.
Yeah.
With the,
the uh,
well I was on news radio and he was
trying to find one guy to play this
piece.
Core Group of Peace Corps guys.
It's like something along those funny.
Actually,
I thought it was funny.
You know,
who knows why people do and don't do
certain projects or some pilots go and
then other shows that are just terrible.
Just stay on the air for a long period
of time.
It doesn't make any sense,
but the process is fucking hard.
It's not easy to do.
It's like creating a new show and
figuring out the right way to do it and
the right character and you know,
and then how much wacky neighbor do we
need and this is not.
That's like a super complicated thing.
It's chemistry,
right?
It's like a.
all these moving parts have to work in.
You know,
Alec Baldwin said one time when a
movie's successful,
it's a fucking accident.
And,
and the reason it's an accident is there
are so many moving parts that any little
thing can go wrong,
including the weather,
including some crazy shoots up a movie
theater,
including whatever it might be,
and if not,
if everything isn't working perfectly
and uses the gym,
the gym carry the ace Ventura thing.
He was doing the getaway.
It was this huge movie.
Kim bessinger him.
They were the remake of the Steve
McQueen thing is biggest movie and along
comes and they were,
they were going to be number one,
not all this tracking that way and along
comes this little movie called Ace
Ventura pet detective and fucking just
steals the whole show,
you know,
and he was saying if a movie does really
well,
it's a fucking accident man.
Everything's got to be as terror.
Pet detective probably did greg,
because they love Jim Carrey.
Dude,
or the fuck you want because nobody saw
that coming.
Nobody.
Nobody saw that coming.
They were like,
look,
we've got Jim Carrey.
Yeah.
What are you going to do,
Jim?
Good character.
It does this fucking wacky over the top
shit.
Everybody loves it.
I died.
Yeah.
I had so many people.
I saw a critically at the time they were
just destroying that movie and talking
about what if he says shit,
it is howling,
but that,
that idea that everybody needs to do the
same kind of comedy is so stupid.
Like you can't appreciate a wacky.
I know that you like Lewis Black,
but can't you like a wacky guy too?
Like what do you,
why are you like holding them back?
How many snap,
man?
What about,
did you see burt wonderstone?
How did that move?
You do?
I don't know what that is.
I heard it was awful.
Oh yeah.
What is it?
It's a magic carrie.
And then Steve Carell and all.
It's a new movie,
isn't he?
Didn't he get in trouble because he was
making fun of Charlton Heston?
Yeah.
Yeah,
he did.
I didn't see the video.
Do you want to watch it?
Let's pull it up.
Apparently he did some controversial
video where he was,
uh,
he was mocking Charlton Heston who's
dead and you know,
one of his famous keep brushing me.
No,
no,
no.
From you.
You know,
you'd taken my rifle when he prime my
cold,
dead cold hands.
Yeah.
Well,
apparently a Jim Carey took that out of
context.
Who apparently.
Michael Morris.
There's no out of context.
This is out of context.
When you say you'll take my rifle out of
my cold dead hands.
It's impossible to take that out of
context.
You only say that when either a,
you're joking around or be your fucking
psycho.
There's one or two things and I think
that Charlton Heston was a fucking side.
There's the third thing.
He was just being dramatic.
Yeah,
he's a psycho.
That guy like guns and.
Yeah,
you were going to have to kill them for
it.
Do we have the video,
the funny or die video?
I think it is.
Yeah.
Let's see this because I.
This is the first time saying that it's
hall.
Why did the Ventriloquist quit drinking?
He was I.
I'd like a room.
Yeah.
Well,
I and how to find folks and welcome back
to d hall.
This is a really long video,
so hold on,
hold on.
Often
it's an absolute pleasure to be here in
the shade of an.
He would be laughing if it weren't for
the Patriots who answered the call of
freedom.
The aliens.
It would explode our every weakness and
suck the brains out of every living
soul.
They'd be laughing but not like you and
me.
They'd go,
this is making me dumb.
Or just watch a five minute video.
That six minute video people really
upset about this.
It was on CNN.
Charlton Heston movies are no longer the
angels
masturbating with a gun in his hand
from his goal.
That takes a trigger.
We're watching mental illness.
This is madness that anybody put that
together,
watched it and went.
I think it's good.
Let's let this out,
man.
Is your allergies really fucking you up
right now?
No.
No,
no.
Why?
Because it's like super extreme outside
right now.
Like for indoor allergens or dust and
dander.
I don't have allergies.
Meaning that I'm lucky.
Yeah,
I'm lucky.
except a gluten intolerance.
I don't think I've ever seen a thing
like watched a cartoon or something like
that and been offended.
Like,
what?
What are you talking about?
How can anybody be offended?
I'm offended that they stole three
minutes of my time watching Jim Carrey
to a guy that died 80 years.
My belief system isn't that shot that
I'm,
you know,
you're going to say something that's
going to throw me into a tizzy.
Well,
not only that,
but because there's a reaction to that
where you,
you.
I mean,
he's obviously knowing that.
What he's doing is sort of
controversial,
so in,
in,
in that,
in sort of accepting that what he's
doing and what he's making fun of,
it's so mild because it's like the fact
that he's doing it at all because what's
supposed to be a controversial about it,
you know,
he's always to mock Charlton Heston.
So you've got like this artificial like
energy that you think is attached to a
bit,
but that's something tached to a bit for
me.
Okay.
Because it's not controversial to me.
It's not at all.
So I just kind of dumb like,
why are you even thinking about Charlton
Heston?
You're talking about a dead guy that
says something weird a long time ago.
Like if you were really.
If you really had something to say,
it should be a lot funnier than that.
I agree.
Like that's silly.
It's silly,
it's folly,
but you always wonder,
like a guy like Jim Carey who starts off
as career with that sort of ace Ventura
thing.
We've just,
or fire Marshall Bill number that
completely over the top hilarious shit.
No,
you can't do that when you're 60.
Okay.
Nobody wants to see Jerry Lewis was
fucking fake Japanese teeth when he's 60
now.
He didn't want to see that.
You know,
you,
you don't mind it when he's 25 or 30.
It's kind of silly and Wacky,
but you,
there's a transitionary period for those
types of comedians where it gets weird.
Shit gets weird when they're hitting 40,
you know,
like Emo,
Philips,
like sort of sort of dropped that thing,
you know,
he will do a thing like this where he
would move all around the stage and
talk,
trying to crazy.
I can.
I can never got that.
It hurts my brain.
He doesn't do it anymore.
You can't do it anymore.
Now I now he does stand up.
So it's like you're,
you're in your,
you're in a trap like the,
you,
you're,
you're looking at a beautiful flower and
it ain't going to last.
That's right.
You better learn how to reinvent
yourself right quick.
It's fucking hard.
Well,
bobcat goldthwait eventually sort of
reinvented himself.
I think he was held by that sort of
screaming,
which is hilarious.
I mean,
when you nail something as good as his
character,
it must be so hard to let go.
I mean,
that character,
that Bobcat goldthwait character and
that he did so many fucking police
academy movies.
He did comedy specials.
You ever seen me?
You're listening to meet Bob.
Who's a Sunday fucking great guy.
I know him.
I mean,
I've worked with them.
I've worked with him twice and he's a
great guy.
He's a really smart dude who's really
kind of understated and quiet.
Actually.
Exact opposite.
He had to.
He had abandoned the bobcat character.
You know,
it makes me laugh.
Do you know one of the funniest human
being tough fucking planet is,
um,
a.
Oh God.
A botox.
Ha.
Gilbert gottfried.
The.
Oh,
he's very funny.
Oh my gosh.
We're just hanging out with that guy.
Oh my God.
Well,
he's real old school.
Legit comment.
You know what I mean?
He's,
he's,
he's been around forever.
Gilbert's been legit forever.
And he still,
he'll still tweet ridiculous shit and
get fired from campaigns and shit.
And it's just because that's who he is
and he's awesome.
You know,
I celebrate that Shit.
I think that the kind of guys who say
like really ridiculous preposterous shit
and offensive shit,
like,
uh,
Gilbert godfried and do it on a regular
basis,
that's why is it okay for you to have a
movie where you're pretending that
you're a bad guy shooting cops?
Why is that okay?
And it's not okay for Gilbert gottfried
to pretend to be some crazy man who's
making fun of aids.
I called them up.
I called him up to it and aids for
children with AIDS benefit that I do
every year and I couldn't,
I couldn't,
I couldn't even send that to the minute
he goes,
Bob,
that kids with,
hey,
stop using drugs.
And he just kept saying it over and over
again.
I'm fucking dying.
I'm not doing.
I like it.
He just wouldn't let me get it out.
And he hung up on me.
I was like,
all right,
well he's legit.
He's the real deal,
you know,
he's a real comic.
He's so funny.
Do you know that feeling like a real
comic?
You know,
we all have that thing where there's,
there's,
what is it?
It's being.
When you say that you guys real comic,
and I know exactly what you mean,
not being as some phony being you're
being,
you know,
you,
you believe the person.
That's who that guy is,
man,
I'm for better or for worse,
that's who he is on stage that had been
run into a comic at the airport and it's
like Chucky Mc fuck-all sticks and like
some,
some do.
That's hacking it up around all over the
country and you know,
one of those guys,
he's just like,
oh Jesus,
like,
oh,
you'll hide your head and look down,
but if you see bill burr,
you know you're going to go like bell.
What's up?
I feel good about the world.
You see God don't break.
Oh,
that guy's legit.
That's a real guy.
A real human being.
I can actually have a conversation with.
Well not only that,
I mean,
it's like when you run into them,
if you run into a fellow comedian,
it's like it's a,
it's sort of a rare fraternity.
Yes.
There's not a lot of us out there.
No.
If you get lucky and run into one when
you're on the road,
a language,
you know,
there's an intimacy there that like sort
of that you know,
that you can't have an experience that
most people haven't had,
you know,
that you have.
You can't really share with other people
as much,
you know,
like,
just the would be like that with
everything.
I mean,
it must be like that for brain surgeons,
you know,
imagine this,
be like some famous neurosurgeon and all
of a sudden you're on a flight with
another famous neurosurgeon.
Like,
oh,
well do you believe you've been using
for techniques and finding that stumps
blood clots,
you know,
like it's,
it seems like that would be the case
with everything,
you know,
just sort of massage she was talking
about that you find,
you know,
whatever it is,
find what it is.
It's a language.
I mean,
you know,
it's a language.
Every.
Everything is the language.
You know,
you,
you get more and more fluent with
things.
I mean,
think about what Jujitsu is.
Jujitsu,
language,
man's physical language,
you know,
and there are answers to what,
what somebody gives to you and,
and,
and somebody doesn't speak that language
is fucked.
Yeah,
you know,
everything is that way.
And by the way,
it's also part of that language is
rhythm.
There's a rhythm,
there's a,
there's a speed,
there's a tempo to everything that you
do and it varies on what you're doing,
you know,
that there's a and,
and,
and your personality informs what that
rhythm is.
You know,
some guys when they do get to her
fucking explosive and crazy and then
other guys are really passive and just
lock you up when they need to.
Just all depends on what your expression
of the thing it is you're doing,
you know,
and you can always feel and you can
always tell when someone is authentic,
not only because they last for a long
time,
but I really think human beings have.
You're keyed in.
We all have antenna for what's legit.
We all have like,
like sensitive antenna for what's.
You can get fooled for a little while
when you're young,
but at the end of the day,
you know,
I think we all have a sort of A.
I think if you're lying to yourself,
you can get fooled fairly easily.
That's the thing with these scams.
Most people are aligned to themselves.
Most people have to lie to themselves in
order to keep a job or a wife,
a husband or you know,
there's a little bit.
Yeah,
it was a lot of people that have to kind
of bullshit themselves,
you know,
and uh,
it's not even that they have to bullshit
themselves.
It also could be that they got on a path
of bullshitting themselves at one point
in time to sort of access too thick and
too many responsibilities without though
they've moved on in their career.
They're moving forward in life.
Like I knew a dude who was a,
he
had done movies,
okay,
but he was still full of shit.
It was like a movie star.
But he would lie to you.
He would lie to you about like fake
kickboxing matches that he had talked to
you about all these different things
that he was doing.
He definitely wasn't doing it.
He would just make shit up so he.
He had still been connected to the all
this whatever,
whatever negative thing that he had held
onto it.
He's still never realized how to let it
go while he was advancing and all these
other areas in his life.
So while he becoming a successful
millionaire movie star,
he was also still a liar.
You see that a lot.
I know.
I know somebody who's got just this like
on paper,
their life is so fucking amazing.
They're looking lots of money,
crazy,
nice house,
healthy,
great kids,
successful,
and they are taking lots of anti
depressants just to get out of bed
because there's something fucking and
it's not a chemical thing so much for
them.
It's just this malaise,
dissatisfaction,
anxiety.
They're always suffering from.
Well,
I think it's also an example,
an excellent example of that super
complicated machine being run by an
incompetent driver.
If it's not an emotional or it's not a
chemical problem in your brain,
if it's not a disease or a disorder
that's giving you the wrong amount of
hormones and it's some sort of a
behavioral issue that you've picked up
over the years and a pattern of you keep
repeating over and over again,
that's a sign of someone who was given a
very complicated thing,
human life and didn't know how to fuck
to drive it.
Just slammed it into trees and fucked it
up and got hooked on meth and just went
crazy with it.
Didn't know what it was doing right?
Instead of someone who like who had
never lived in a physical form,
you ethereal and nature and the universe
gives you an opportunity.
Hey,
listen,
we've got an opening down on earth.
If you want a,
we have a baby human available loving
household.
Everyone is dedicated to the idea of
taking this baby human and developing
into a full form functional human being.
So you've got an excellent support
system behind you,
but you're going to have to start from
scratch.
Okay?
You're gonna know no knowledge
whatsoever right out of the gate you're
going to have to.
People will teach you at first and then
you're gonna have to develop a voracious
appetite for knowledge.
All in all,
it's going to take about shit 30 years
before you even know how to fucking do
anything correctly or fit in with the
other people in your realm,
but hey,
it's better than being gas,
so what do you want to do?
Do you want to be a spirit of the next
stage of afterlife,
fucking chance and ride a human flesh
machines to the brink of the end of
civilization.
Come on.
I liked that.
He said,
that's a really cool theme to write a
story about.
You want to be gas,
you want to ride this human flesh
machine.
It's very possible that that's what
happened.
I mean,
this idea of like the world being a
simulation.
Maybe it's not a simulation in a sense
that maybe a session,
maybe the whole thing is fucking crazy
and blips
in and out of realities and maybe you
are some sort of gaseous sole form in
another dimension and then you live this
life as a person and then you pop out
the other side and and or some other
thing that's so crazy.
You can't even imagine it right now
because it's not in the realm of
experiences that a human can possibly
experience on this earth.
So much like having a crazy six grand
mushroom trip until you've done it.
You don't.
You can't even imagine what you're
talking about here.
You can't imagine it and so when you
talk about it,
you're just talking nonsense.
You just making noises with your mouth.
So when we leave this and move to the
next thing,
if it is,
if there is such a reality and it's
possible that the next thing will be so
fucking strange,
you can't even imagine like instead of
thinking about ourselves as this
disconnected a human being,
driving around in cars and using the
Internet,
the next thing could be no physical body
at all,
but,
but just constantly connected with a
tangible feeling of contact of other
entities and lifeforms and souls and
pattern.
It's almost like being part of the
Matrix as part of the Internet,
right?
I mean,
if you think about that,
that's certainly what I'm just
listening.
I'm listening to fucking all the
socrates and they says,
you know,
you're,
you're kind of in prison by this body,
this body that kind of breaks down this
body that distracts you constantly with
your appetites,
with food,
sex,
and just pain,
sleep and all the things.
And it distracts you from the work at
hand.
The real work that did this
contemplation on,
on,
you know,
the truth.
Getting to the truth of the essence of
things.
And,
and,
and it's true.
It's like,
if you think about it,
the idea is he says,
he as he was dying,
he goes,
look,
man,
I spent my whole life trying to separate
myself from this physical body,
like I treat all my appetite's with
quiet contempt.
And he says,
finally I get to be rid of this shit
and,
and just be a mind.
And he was like really looking forward
to.
It's kind of profound.
That's a great statement that he treats
all of his appetites with content.
That's a great sense,
right?
And so many intellectual sort of share
that they call it the hair loss,
the first journey,
your hunger or your sexuality or as it
is a distraction.
It is,
it should be treated with quiet contempt
as you know it should,
it should be treated as the last fucking
gasps of a fun life.
Jesus Christ.
We want to just sit around with no
boners on your couch reading a dumb
book.
But the idea is actually getting to the
essence of the truth is more fun,
you know,
but uh,
and it's,
you know,
it's,
uh,
it's getting the essence of the truth is
more fun.
But ultimately,
if you are to believe that this is a
temporary existence,
it's fruitless.
Doesn't matter.
Well,
that's what she'd been enjoying this
ride.
That was aristotle's rebuttal to
socrates.
Aristotle said,
yes,
we should try to strive to be just a
mind.
But by the way,
watch a woman give child birth and you
tell me we're not physical fucking
beings.
We're physical beings with appetites and
you can get yourself to a point where
you feel really good physically and
mentally.
So why not do that?
You know what I always say when it comes
to socrates,
this is an important
one to repeat whenever anybody says
anything about soccer too.
So you should always include.
Yeah.
And you know,
he fucked a lot of dudes.
He actually didn't invent.
Yes,
I love all his friends.
Did you fuck some boys soccer days
folks?
And one of the things that Credo always
complained about as he tried to seduce
them and citizen because he was married
with two kids and he could never do it
to do so.
No creative,
try to seduce them.
Socrates,
socrates,
they talk about that motherfucker stand
there during the war and he used to.
He could nobody,
nobody.
They said with Dan,
lack of sleep cold and lack of food
better than socrates,
nobody can drink more wine and stay
sober.
And one day he stopped and he started
thinking and the soldiers,
garlic shitty town of he's thinking and
they all sat there and watched him think
and they took bets on how long he'd
stand in one place.
And pretty soon the stan started to come
down and they pulled their fucking cops
out to watch him sleep.
And he stood there all fucking night
figuring out this problem.
The answer to an issue.
To me,
meanwhile,
I bet that's a lie.
I bet that never happened.
I bet.
Exaggerate the shit out of everything.
Remember talking about,
in fact,
I didn't even know them.
We did that about my talk when I'm
saying we all do that,
but our teacher's like,
Oh yeah,
your fight teacher.
The greatest,
you know he can jump over trains.
Right?
What studies this Kung Fu with allows
them to kill Moose with his fucking bare
hands.
Yeah.
Who knows my.
When you get to those kind of stories,
it's like,
God,
what really did happen?
Who is who is responsible for writing
down the actual events of the time and
it's funny because if you just go with
human nature,
we would always think,
yeah,
what's wrong with a little elaboration?
I'm going to spice it up.
Good for the Romans.
Look,
we did a great job.
We brought them civilization and no,
he didn't kill that many babies.
They say we killed babies.
Like whatever,
man.
There are people with insane powers of
concentration that can sit and not move
for 24 hours.
Yeah,
they're,
they're autistic.
Yeah.
Well,
now that,
there,
there are people who like somerset mom
wrote a book called the stone arguments
man,
bro,
Bro,
I got this one.
You're actually,
you're actually,
if you're intense,
you'll play quake for 15.
That's why I won't play it.
That's amazing.
You've always been insanely intensive.
I said I remember I said,
hey,
you should try golf.
He,
I'm not fucking playing golf.
If you get into it and it'll be over.
No,
no,
because you'll go crazy.
Yeah.
If I.
If I got into golf and started taking
lessons,
I would play golf all day.
That shit takes a long time.
Like if I could play pool,
you know you can play pool for a half
hour,
right?
You can go and you go,
hey,
I got a half hour.
You wanna hit some balls around and you
can enjoy yourself a half an hour
office,
five hours every time you do it right.
You gotta walk,
you gotTa follow that,
take a cart.
Whatever you gotta do you gotta drive.
Then you got to follow.
You're hitting this thing and it's
fucking.
Why do you tell your car?
That's kind of a bitch mode because I
get exhausted playing golf because some
shit.
Some things make me feel like I have
diabetes tagged with my five year old
and fucking and fucking golf.
Some shit is just too.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Jujitsu
and kettle bells.
I'm not one of those chimp kettlebells.
Do that shit right now.
Walk though and play golf to golf.
I get exhausted.
It's too much.
I walked a mile.
My legs,
my legs.
I can't.
If I'm bored,
I fucking.
I fall asleep.
Well,
you remember the steven no hunting
thing,
which comes out April 28th on the sports
network were Brian and I went out to say
what it is a sportsman's network
outdoors channeling you.
I loved watching Joe and I just watched
it and I was so.
All these great memories were brought
back,
but I was really impressed.
I thought it was.
They did it.
They did a really good job.
Matt shot at well,
they edited it well.
It was funny.
Great music.
By the way.
This is bullshit,
man.
Sportsmans channel.
It is a two point one rating an imd be
fucking silly.
Liberals are going to be famous.
Here's the thing.
First of all,
that is so wrong because it was a great
show.
That is a.
This is the only show.
Okay.
If you,
if you're like me and you have any,
if you eat meat,
okay,
and you have any desire for some sort of
intellectual connection to the animal
that cheat.
There's not a lot of people that
represent you.
If you're a thinking person,
it's not a lot of people that represent
you.
In the sportsman's world.
We have this idea that sportsmen and
hunters are this like these idiots,
these,
these fucking numb minded Republican
Republican robots and they're out there
just fucking shooting animals because
they're evil.
Watch this show because this is not that
at all.
This is Steve Rinella who's a good
friend now to Brian and myself.
He's an awesome guy and a really well
read individual with a deep knowledge of
especially the history of the
colonization of the West and and a deep
love for animals,
but deep love for animals and an
understanding of the whole process of
acquiring your own meat and the way he
does it,
he does it through this idea.
It's called fair chase hunting where
he's not like,
sometimes they'll like setup and I don't
have a problem with this.
I'm just saying this is one of the ways
that people go hunting.
It makes it more effective.
Like you'll set out bait and the animal
will come to the food and then when it's
at the food you're hiding in a blind and
you shoot it.
That's like super calm after that.
That's Ted nugent's entire show by the
way.
I like Ted nugent and I liked Ted nugent
show.
I don't agree with them on a lot of his
things that he says,
especially when it comes to politics and
there's a lot of nonsense and a lot of
his words.
But I think,
uh,
he's a fascinating character and he's
out there shooting animals and telling
everybody to go fuck themselves.
He shot a coyote in the head with a,
with an air rifle on the show and then
was like,
oh look,
a great coyote threw it in the back of
his Ted fucking new children.
One with an air rifle.
Yeah.
Think about this.
This is not,
I mean this is like he's a big rock star
and at one point in time when I was a
kid,
Ted nugent was fucking huge.
Lot of cons to this day,
stranglehold is one of my all time
favorite.
Classic rock hits the live version.
You got me in that.
God Damn Amazing.
He's.
He's crazy though,
but I like them.
I know I don't like me.
No,
I don't like everything about them.
I don't like them all across the board,
but Steve Rinella represents a
completely different time.
He's not Ted nugent's leaving bait out
and he shoot.
He shot three deer with a bow and Arrow
in the first 15 minutes of just show the
other day.
I mean,
I don't even know.
I mean how many they let you eat that
much.
He's got to give away a lot.
He gives away.
Yeah.
Hunters for the homeless are hunters for
the hungry rather.
But yeah,
they,
they know.
They know animal goes to waste.
They mean he has a guy that butchers and
shit.
He's shown it on the show before.
That's not mean Ted nugent not doing
that.
He's definitely given a lot of food way.
He just likes doing it,
you know,
and whatever man the fuck,
I mean,
what,
why is that bad?
But the guy who runs this dairy farm or
you know,
a slaughter and steers to make your
cheeseburger,
that guy is acceptable,
right?
Like,
that doesn't make any sense the way he's
doing it.
Even the way Ted nugent doing it by
leaving out bait and shooting it with an
Arrow when it comes to eat.
So fucking what?
That's still way more ethical.
Way Smarter.
Like,
why wouldn't you do that?
Don't you have some extra corn?
What do you want to traipse around the
fucking forest looking for some animal?
Just leave the corn out.
Shoot it.
Well,
what's the goal?
The goal is you have to shoot it until
you've been out there at five in the
morning,
freezing your dick off after sleeping in
a tent.
You fucking use bait right quick,
especially if you're a hungry man.
This guy,
Steve Rinella,
though he doesn't do any of that.
His is all fair chase hunting and he's a
really bright guy and we have this
really ignorant stereotype that people
that grew up in sort of hunting,
fishing backgrounds are dummies.
You know,
a lot of people do,
a lot of people who don't have any
experience in hunting.
And I think the beautiful thing about
this show is you guys are fucking great
writer.
I mean,
he's a great writer.
His book,
very good book.
It's very,
he's just descriptions or captivate you.
Like he's got a really intelligent way.
I learned a lot from.
Yeah.
So uh,
my parents about the difference between
hunting in a blind or,
or fair chase hunting.
Yeah.
But I was talking about something before
that.
I don't,
I don't remember what the hell it was
that's called going on,
a tangent son hit.
But the people that have a problem with
basically anything that people do
because people that have.
What about all the restaurants?
Everywhere you go,
they're serving me.
Like why are you freaking out about
certain specific situations where you
find meat,
you know,
and why is it really meet because are,
what are these animals?
Can they do,
if you don't eat them,
are they just going to live forever or
if they're not gonna live forever,
they going to live a certain amount of
time and then what happens to the meat?
Is it okay to feed it to dogs once they
die of old age?
Is that.
Is that allowed?
You know,
but what?
What do we do as humans to control the
population?
We have spent a lot of money on
sterilization programs.
What if our health deteriorates because
we're
not eating as much animal protein and
other countries take over and start
dominating us.
Marcy ran the army.
Do you now,
quickly,
we'd be over quickly.
The Soviets would fucking take over.
Think Putin would standard if one,
if Maurice,
he became the president of the gun.
They these fucking meet headed fic tree
trunk.
Next Russian cosmonauts would come
running over and just dominate this
country.
She's turned into a bunch of
Vegetarians.
That's.
We live in a hard world,
ladies and gentlemen.
Okay,
and you can't run it on lentils.
You just can't.
Paula by general hugging.
You can't run it on lentils.
Fox,
silly fucks.
That's why he hasn't won.
I don't think they want a metal last
Olympics.
I'm like,
come on guys,
you got a billion people I love and not
making anybody from India.
I love India.
I love it.
But.
But like you're not athletic.
They're not as athletic as some
countries.
Sweden,
it's got 7 million people.
They went like fucking 50 gold metals in
Olympics because meals are hot.
One trying really hard to get laid and
the only way to do that as be awesome at
a sport.
That's the quickest way to be funny you,
but even that's not provable enough.
As a young man you can't fuck with the
quarterback.
Guy was a basketball star.
That guy,
that guy,
the guy who hits the home runs.
That guy wins that guy.
When I was a wrestler,
they didn't come out to see me in my
fucking single out at 125 pounds and not
give a fuck about shit about that.
Yeah.
They didn't give a fuck about wrestlers
and they certainly weren't into fucking
karate guys.
No,
you're a karate guy.
Doing Great.
What do you wear?
Pajamas and fucking stick your feet and
people's face and how stupid that is.
No,
we can't have sex kit out of here,
but the fucking quarterbacks,
they just have to beat them off with
sticks and get out of here.
You fucking opportunistic hooker.
I'm going to go practice my sidekick.
I'll be right back.
Yeah.
They like,
what are you doing?
Why do you do that?
Where do you do it?
What do you do that that's you.
That's all you do.
Not Flashing to play another sport.
Even the USC and now it's.
These guys were like bad asses and a lot
of girls like,
no,
no.
Those guys hit each other and their ears
are all weird.
What are you talking about?
Those?
Those guys have to beat it off with that
in their circle.
They share.
It's crazy what girls girl just like
hate each other.
That is a broken bit.
Doesn't want to go on a wild ride.
UFC guys don't get the same kind of
attention that basketball football
players do.
Man,
are you crazy?
You think you like garlic?
Chuck Odell in his prime.
You'd never seen anything like that in
the face of the earth.
You've never seen fucking that guy would
show up when chuck Liddell was the
fucking champion in the UFC,
the UFC light heavyweight champion,
and he wouldn't walk into a club.
He W,
w you've never seen gravity like daily.
He would suck in hot titted asteroids.
Boom.
He was like Jupiter absorbing grit.
They were just hugging him,
wanting to take pictures with him and
hugging him,
want to take pictures with them,
do it.
It was a swarm.
It was like,
have you seen that commercial for a
World War z while the Zombie swarm?
That's what it was.
When chocolate,
Dell would show up,
girls would just flock to him.
He's the gladiator.
They couldn't help the Alpha male he
wanted to meet and they wanted to talk
to him and the guy like literally
couldn't move through the room.
I've never seen anything like it hung
with Mike Tyson and they say the same
thing.
No idea.
Especially because in Vegas a lot of
those girls are drunk.
When you're drunk,
that's when the real thoughts come out
and you're like a picture with my DNA.
Your DNA takes out.
Give a fuck.
I'm gonna.
Tell him right now,
suck as God.
I don't give a fuck.
That's my thing.
I'm going to do it.
It should go.
Meanwhile,
no girl would support that.
It's like you fucking whore.
They might need them to,
but I don't want you to suck his Dick
First.
Oh my God.
He and in his,
uh,
his one man show,
he starts by saying,
yeah,
if you with those coco cafe,
and it's,
let me get one of those two buddy in his
one man show.
He basically says he puts up the number.
I didn't see it basically puts up the
number 400 million.
And he goes,
I lost all that money.
Oh my gosh,
Dale,
I made 400 million and I lost 400
million.
No Shit.
You know?
But that's what happens.
You just buy a bunch of tigers and just
like fucking everything.
Well,
it's also the kind of mentality that
allows you to become a prize fighter,
that kind of mentality that allows you
to be a person who risks his health and
runs at men in a,
in a boxing ring and smashes that
brands,
you know,
you're thinking about the moment,
man,
you're thinking about training for your
next fight.
You thinking about months of
preparation,
you thinking about the fight itself.
You probably also have to be a little,
like you have to be pretty aggro,
right?
For sure.
But it's also like someone telling you
what you can and can't do with your
money.
But like bitch,
I'm Hector Camacho.
I'll do whatever the fuck I want.
I'm going to get my trio man in
diamonds.
Suck my Dick.
Okay.
Alright.
So it's going to say macho man,
suck my Dick.
You get whatever you want.
I mean if you're a champion,
it's almost like you have to have that
mentality to be that Mike Tyson type of
a character.
You know,
Bernard Hopkins,
like famously frugal,
you know,
he uh,
he's just a smart disciplined guy that's
still at 48 years old world boxing
champion.
The craziest thing I've ever.
No one's ever done that before.
No one's ever done at 48 years old and
look fucking good.
He looked great.
He box the shit out of that dude.
It wasn't,
it wasn't a close to crazy.
He's a master.
He's a master boxer,
but he's like Super Frugal,
you know?
But his style is like super frugal.
That's why at 48 years old,
he's still in the mix.
Whereas a guy like Mike Tyson,
when she says,
and he fucking,
he raged for a few years and then done
Mike Tyson and Bernard Hopkins,
they were boxing at the same time.
You know Bernard Hopkins is older.
Yeah.
Bernard Hopkins is the older man and
they were bought in.
Bernard Hopkins is still a world
champion,
still speaks fluent is no voice
problems.
So articulate so articulately,
does not get hit very well.
Knows how to roll with things.
He's never been hurt.
Never been hurt even when he's been
tagged.
But he's been tagged by guys in drop
them,
you know,
he just starts boxing and he's
disciplined is fuck.
And he sticks that fucking boxing game
in your face.
And slowly but surely he starts to
overwhelm when he beat Kelly pavlick and
he goes,
he grabbed him apparently,
and he said,
don't let this ruin you.
You know,
he uh,
he knew he was going to be the money
walk in the ring to be that good.
Kelly Pavlich was a fucking killer.
That's a,
that's an exceptional fight.
But the defining fight was Felix
Trinidad because Felix Trinidad was
thought to be a destroyer.
I mean,
people were setting up Felix Trinidad
to,
you know,
fight all these super fights.
Wasn't going to fight Oscar de la Hoya,
he's gonna fight like a lot of different
people at Felix Trinidad was a killer.
He's a serious high level dangerous
threat.
And Bernard Hopkins blocked his fucking
face off.
He just boxed his fucking ears off
credible and,
and just shut them down.
And it was amazing that people thought
the Trinidad was the favorite going into
that fight because Bernard Hopkins
fucking dominated him.
I mean,
he dominated him and he stopped him and
it ended Felix Trinidad feel extreme.
That was never the same after that
fight.
That was.
That was the fight where he hit the
wall.
They say for fighters always have one
fight that like even get hit one time by
one.
It's one punch.
Usually that changes that whole mix.
Well you can say like GSP was not the
same fighter.
He became very conservative and careful
after he got knocked out by Matt Serra,
well he definitely became more
conservative but controls you rather
than GSP,
which you've got to look out and people
say,
Oh,
you know,
this is gsp slowing down or is GSP.
This was GSP that and you know,
is this time over or new guy's going to
beat them.
There's always going to be a bunch of
fucking killers out there.
scary.
Johny Hendricks,
Jake ellenberger type dudes looking to
smash your fucking face and when you're
the champ there's no getting around
that.
What's most impressive is that the guy
has been doing this for so fucking long
and when shit starts happening,
like he blew out his acl,
look getting injured,
that is a normal part of being an
athlete.
It happens.
There's no getting around it.
You're putting your body through
incredible strains and you're especially
doing an improvisational sort of a thing
like wrestling or Jujitsu or kickboxing
where you you don't know how he's gonna
move or you're going to be expiring and
Shit goes wrong and you can get hurt.
There's no doubt.
There's no way of avoiding that,
but when shit starts breaking and you
start getting injured and you start
thinking about the amount of hours this
guys put in the gym,
the amount of hours guys put in the
cage,
he amount of fights,
amount of wear and tear.
It's just a matter of how long can you
consistently keep up that sort of
fighting intensity and all wrestling
based fighting style too,
which is very taxing on your spinal
cord,
very taxing on your knees.
You know there's a lot of power in
involved in a wrestling base style.
Even if you're a technical guy like a
Ben Aspirin,
it's like it becomes a difficult style
to to incorporate what's of about him
though.
It's gsps his ability and also there's a
lot of tape on them.
You can watch a lot on him.
You can like.
You can try to figure him out,
but he fights a different fight in some
ways.
Every time he fights as well.
It's,
it's,
I think,
don't get me wrong.
I think like a wrestling based style is
definitely the best way to approach it
as far as longevity,
but even that it's like how much
longevity can.
MMA is a brutal Goddamn game.
How much longevity can you get a certain
point in time.
Someone's going to come along and if
Anderson Silva keeps fighting,
someone's probably going to beat him.
You know,
and it might be sort of a Bernard
Hopkins situation where no one ever
gets.
I mean,
he's so clever and so technical that no
one ever gets to the point where they
can really humiliate them,
but there'll be a guy like a chat dawson
who come along and beat Bernard Hopkins
because he was younger and quicker.
You know,
there's going to be these Andre Ward
type.
Gosh,
it's going to be the dude that,
uh,
Jermaine,
the guy that I'm Kelly pavlock beat.
I want to say Jermaine,
Andrea,
but that's not his name,
his name.
So a lot of his fights.
He was the champ and he beat 'em.
I don't know if that's the right box or
African.
His fucking name.
Shit.
I hate that.
I got too many fucking names.
My brain.
But this dude,
this name Andre?
No,
no,
he's an MMA fighter.
Oh,
well.
that's right.
I remember that dude.
Yeah,
sorry.
Sorry.
Jermaine.
Yeah.
He's actually a very talented,
a kickboxing champion.
I'm Jermaine Stewart.
Jimmy Taylor.
Taylor Taylor.
Yeah.
Jermaine.
Andrea says,
sorry.
Bad ass looking dude was crazy.
I saw the one tail.
It's got a shaved head and the crazy
ponytail he fought in the UFC,
I think.
Pretty sure.
Um,
but uh,
he beat Kelly pavlock knocked him out,
but he beat Bernard Hopkins twice and he
beat him with speed plead.
He beat him twice.
He's a,
he's a bigger guy and he's but pablet.
Meanwhile pavlock beat him,
but he was just able to out athlete.
It's so funny looking at Kylie look like
he like this.
If you saw him on the beach and shorts,
he couldn't look more normal.
There's not a lot of muscle tone.
He's covered with some kind of.
After he had his kind of thing.
He had a bit of a breakdown.
Then he went and got about sat too,
but a lot of alcohol.
Apparently.
It's before that,
when he was younger,
he had no tattoos,
you know,
very few.
It was just annoying.
He just retired,
you know,
I think,
yeah,
I think part of it,
I mean,
the alcohol thing,
it's very possible that the depression,
alcohol,
that stuff has to do with head trauma to
that.
Right?
Yeah.
And he thinks it might be as well.
And so he's retiring even though he's
like,
he,
he won recently and he looked really
good too.
He was in the midst of a comeback.
He's a talented fucking boxer.
Yeah.
Yes.
But getting,
getting hit in the head,
walking around with headaches all day.
You could have done it,
man.
It was done.
It.
Keep it.
It's,
it's not fun.
I mean,
I never did it to the extent that he did
it though when he,
he did was incredible.
And he's a world champion and the amount
of,
just the amount of punishment that you
have to go through just in the rain
dude.
I mean it's his Jesus Christ.
Just.
I mean,
my main,
the training ring,
you know,
just everyday in the gym,
these guys,
you know,
they,
they get caught all the time warm.
And the last time we fought was 2012.
He Won.
And apparently he was a,
they were setting up a new fight for
them.
You can get your own fucking computer.
No Way.
You want to see a picture of him?
Yeah.
What do you want to say?
The Tattoo.
So I'll find them for it.
Yeah.
He had a bunch of crazy tattoos.
Man.
He,
uh,
he went nutty and just fucking tattoo
the shit out of his chest.
Go off.
He put like haunted houses on him and
shit.
Rory Macdonald.
I want to pull that up.
Kelly Pavlik tattoos you could see like
the tattoos that he has on his mind.
Sam Macdonald fight GSP,
but I think their training partners,
um,
apparently they are preparing for that
possibility and they're not training
together anymore.
Yeah.
They,
they prepare on the other opposite sides
of the gym.
I'm going to tell him was no fucking
joke.
Yeah.
Kelly Patrick has like a,
the colosseum on his chest.
He has some nutty shit if you go to the
one,
um,
there's other ones where,
you know,
a kind of a good skinny.
Our image of what it is.
There's another one down there.
If you look at it,
it's got a bit of a better image.
There's a couple of them.
Yeah.
That one was arms are flex to kind of
get to see that what it is.
Yeah.
It's like a Roman colosseum on the left
and there's some,
uh,
some other shit was just get,
just get real random whether tattoos.
He's got an angel with a bow and Arrow
is great.
Look at him.
He's awesome looking.
Is that a fighter?
A bridge?
He's a fucking animal man.
When he was at his best,
he was a really fun guy to watch nipple
locking up.
I'm glad.
I'm glad he's retiring before it gets
ugly.
Mean guide did a lot.
He accomplished a lot and it gets ugly
for everyone.
He looks haunted a little bit.
Doesn't mean it looks.
Guys are my brothers.
A lot of guys are somebody called being
an addict.
Uh,
uh,
like you always feel like you're being
chased by something you know,
described that he said,
you know,
I always feel like I'm being chased by,
by some,
by a demon.
It's almost catching me every time I'm
always running,
I'm always running.
Have you heard about these,
uh,
district attorneys that are getting shot
in Texas?
Some of assassinating district call.
One guy was white supremacy.
He had a shootout.
They killed him.
That was the guy who killed the
Colorado,
was prison bureau chief in India.
Did that,
caught that gun and we got to kill them.
And then the,
the guy who shot the district attorney
and his wife,
they don't know.
I guess they still don't know who did
it.
You know,
you don't even know if it's connected,
but I'm sure it is.
Well,
it might be just a cartel thing.
You don't know man.
Fucking,
I don't know.
Wedding since 1964,
I think.
How many?
Thirteen or 33 prosecutors have been
shot.
Wow.
There was a story that came out about a
cop that may or may not have planted
drugs on a,
on a woman because she was claiming that
a judge had moved in and our.
Oh,
let me pull it up on woman who
complained about judges sexual
solicitation.
Jesus.
Yeah,
I would,
I don't,
I'm not shocked at that.
I mean they found a judge who is
profiting off of sending kids to
juvenile homes.
Really?
Yeah.
They found a judge that was profiting
off of that.
He's in jail now.
It's in Pennsylvania.
So she's pretty sharp.
Pencil.
Yeah.
Sick motherfucker shit know he thought
because these kids had done things in
the past.
Fuck it.
I'll just send them down the river,
you know,
they need it.
And he was getting kickbacks.
Who's getting kickbacks that more
people,
he would convict ascend to these
juvenile homes.
Some more money.
They could spend more money they can get
from the government and the more profit
they can make.
Creepy Fox.
Creepy.
Yeah.
This is a Murray County.
I don't know where the fuck that is.
Murray County sheriff's office.
Where the hell's Mary?
You live in a serious hillbilly place if
no one's.
Yeah.
Oh,
you know what I was going to talk about
my,
my uh,
Vincent Labarbera,
the guy that I podcast right now on the
Bryan County show and this guy,
this guy is a,
is a uh,
first of all he wears a patch or was
that because he went snow blind three
times from climbing,
like fucking huge mountains like in
Africa and stuff.
And,
and.
Yeah.
And he was uh,
he would,
he would go and like basically go to war
zones.
Just see what it's like.
Is it really the counties in Minnesota,
by the way?
I'm a whatever.
This guy went snow blind.
Yeah,
yeah.
From climbing mountains and shit.
He's be able to.
Daredevil,
did all kinds of shit.
But now he's always been a high profile,
a trial lawyer for like big time drug
cartels.
He's a huge proponent on the podcast.
Talks about why drugs should be legal
and stuff too.
Amazing.
So He's,
he's tried to get the cartels out of
jail.
He does.
He just thinks all drugs should be
legal,
all of them.
And he does everything he can to stick
to the government whenever.
So he handles huge or big cases like
big,
big time cases.
Uh,
the marine in Fallujah.
A lot,
a lot of different people,
you know.
And um,
he's got a really interesting take on,
on,
you know,
justice,
like the,
I had this Delta Force Guy I was talking
about killing an American citizen and he
was kind of justifying it and vince in
la by Vera got on.
It was like,
let me tell you something.
That's the biggest bunch of,
you know,
he,
he couldn't have been more on the other
side of it,
the,
that the US and the national defense act
and stuff.
We talk a lot about.
He talked,
he just goes to town on the fact that
that is killing our country,
our due process and everything and he's
very articulate about it.
I'm not,
it's going down the path of corruption
and we all see it and because now we're
all on the Internet,
we all get to talk about it and we get
to express our concerns and get to know
when the government says trust me.
No,
well keeps happening.
That's like this new thing is this
Monsanto bill that just passed silently
through congress without any mainstream
exposure where they're,
you know,
giving Monsanto a,
all sorts of subsidies and all sorts of
abilities to,
to,
uh,
to hide the fact that genetically
modified foods are and things that you
buy.
It's creepy.
It's creepy because it's,
it's one of those things where it's all,
you would hope that they would one day
be.
What was that
was the whistle to your phone,
dude.
Fuck,
that's the gay shit.
I actually kinda like changed my ringer.
A couple of.
What the fuck was I even talking about?
We're talking about Monsanto.
I would hope that things would slowly
start to move into a better direction.
We're going to cut back on corruption.
We're gonna attack it.
We're going to make for a more fair
society.
We're going to only involve ourselves in
military campaigns that are Justin and
true and we're going to try to,
you know,
you got to change the rest of the world
to change the incentive structure if you
want to do that.
Of course,
you know,
it's just weird,
man.
It's,
it's the biggest.
The biggest danger is that when you have
good people behaving corruptly,
when you have a system that allows for
no other way to do business,
so that so that your system becomes an
economy of influence,
that meritocracy.
So who you know is really how you get
business,
not what you can do and that's where
you,
that's,
that's where we're headed in some
aspects and you have to be very careful
of that.
Yeah.
At least Lawrence lessig books as that.
In a republic last,
what I taught,
which I've talked about many times on
this podcast,
is that's a very important book to read
and,
and what he does,
he says,
look,
let me show you how Washington is
corrupt with a lot of good people try to
do the right thing,
but they can't do business without being
[inaudible].
Let me,
let me explain to people don't know what
the fuck we're talking about what this
is,
because this is a pretty crazy shit.
It's a genetically modified food.
Uh,
and the thing they're calling the
Monsanto Protection Act,
which was signed by President Obama.
They're calling it the Monsanto
Protection Act.
What it actually was,
it's,
it was added to an essential spending
bill without congressional hearings.
So they slept this rider and the rider
strips the power from the federal courts
to halt the sales and planting of
genetically modified foods even if
health concerns arise.
Wow.
This is crazy.
The provision was simply an industry
ploy to continue to sell genetically
engineered seeds even without a court,
even when a court of law has found that
they were approved by the u.
s d,
a illegally,
the petition stated it's necessary to
fund an unprecedented tacked on us
judicial review.
Congress should not be meddling with the
judicial review process based solely on
the special interest.
Have a handful of companies.
This is from a,
someone's uh,
I guess it was I,
I don't know who wrote that.
Someone.
Okay.
So essentially they're saying is they
snuck this in and people are just
finding out about it now and that
happens all the time in Washington.
They're trying to protect the profits of
this company.
That's,
that's the only way.
The only reason why you would hide
information as you're trying to protect
the product,
because if the,
if the genetically modified foods are
safe and they're in there and we find
out they're safe,
then we don't have to worry.
But if they might not be safe and you
want to sue,
if you want you,
you,
you're not going to know.
You're not going to be able to blame it
on the genetically modified foods.
You're not even going to know if it's
genetically modified.
If you have health issues that arise
because of the genetically modified
foods,
you won't even know the correlation.
You won't know what if you.
You know what?
If you have a known issue that's come up
on amongst a small percentage of people
that do respond poorly to jump
genetically modified foods,
well you won't even fucking know because
it's not going to be in the label
because some cons got paid and it's
crazy because the people who are selling
genetically modified foods should only
want to be selling healthy genetically
modified foods.
It is possible that science can figure
out a way to produce more food that's
more nutritious.
It is possible,
but it's also possible that they could
fuck it up and when.
When this,
when something like this comes along and
there,
this is all this is,
they should call this the Monsanto
Information Act because all it is is
keeping information secret,
keeping it from people.
That's never.
That's not only that,
it's also keep.
It's also changing information in lying
about what's good for you and what's not
because they're setting up corruption.
They're setting up.
Yeah,
so corruption can take place.
I don't know enough about genetically
modified foods,
but I'll give you an example,
but you don't have to.
Well No,
I'm saying that the,
the food and nutrition board,
which sets the school standard for 30
million children on what they can eat
because they've been hijacked by
companies like Nestle,
et Cetera,
or the big companies that have an
interest in selling their products.
Coca Cola and stuff and and they hire
scientists,
read,
read the China study talks about this,
you know,
I'm paraphrasing here,
but they'll,
they'll hide.
They'll stack the deck with scientists
that they basically hard to say that 25
percent of your diet can be simple
sugars,
which means I can.
I can have vending machines in there
that sell soda and twix bars and seven.
That's part of your lunch.
That's where when you're ignorant and
you don't know how,
how the system works,
how the incentive structure works,
you are going to pay a price for it with
your health and so are your kids.
So that's why I always tell people it's
you can't not be politically committed.
It's not a luxury you can afford,
man,
because what happens is it becomes a
concentration of vested interests.
Look at,
look at Wall Street.
Yes,
they compete with each other until
someone comes in with legislation and
they get very good at hiring lobbyists.
They get very good
at their economy of influence and
figuring out how to buy the right people
to keep business as usual.
That's why you have to teach kids to
entering the system.
Now to stop that pattern,
you know,
they have to figure out a way to profit
overall.
You know the whole thing's a problem
with profit as long as it's earned
honestly,
and you're playing by the rules.
The problem is when you have companies
that stack the deck,
you know of course,
and so,
so how does that happen?
You've got to figure out how that
happens and why it happened,
and then that's the way you change it,
to figure out first how it happens.
Just so transparent when something like
this Monsanto thing comes up because all
they're doing is keeping information.
That's all they're doing.
Exactly.
They should never be able to keep
information because if you have a good
product,
like let's say you're selling oranges,
when you can prove,
if you look at the data that oranges are
very rich in vitamin C,
they have healthy fiber to them.
When you eat an orange with your lunch,
it's probably a really healthy choice.
It's good for you and we have a lot of
data to back that up so all the
information on oranges is readily
available.
You can go look it up.
You know why?
Because there's nothing bad.
There's nothing to hide.
It's a fucking orange.
Okay?
But when you start monkeying around with
oranges and mold,
this is an orange that doesn't react
badly to certain pesticides and this is
an orange that creates its own pesticide
and kills off mosquitoes.
Or this is an orange that you don't tell
me.
Now we got a real problem because that's
not really an orange.
That's an orange that you fucked with
and I don't know if you really know
what's going to happen with that orange.
If I eat one of these a day for the next
20 years,
is that going to write my asshole out?
You know what is,
what is it?
Gonna?
Is it gonna?
Erase my memory.
At least give me the information.
I want to know if he's got the gene of a
jelly fish because it was so,
so it doesn't freeze.
I want to know that executive told me
everything.
Show me everything.
You've got to make my own choices.
You can't hide information.
And the idea that they would do that
with our food,
which is something that's.
We have a health crisis in this country
for sure.
Even though we have access to all of the
information on the back of food,
all of the nutritional information isn't
readily available and almost anything
that we buy in the store except for like
meats and things like that.
But when we do that,
we still don't use it.
We still use that information and so
many people are eating terrible food
everyday and so many people are or
unhealthy and sick all the time and
they're essentially poisoned themselves.
So that's with inflammation.
That's right.
That's when the fucking information with
readily apparent bad things to eat and
people choose them.
You,
you,
you know,
you can't stop inflammation.
You can't because what you're doing is
you're setting yourself up so that you
can lie and protect people in power.
That's the only reason you shouldn't be
doing it.
We already have a problem.
We already have a problem with people
having shitty diets.
We already have a problem with this
weird thing with humans were stuff that
tastes amazing.
It's fucking killing you.
Like krispy Kreme donuts are fucking
delicious,
but that's a toxin.
Yeah.
Those are like pure sugar.
You go to a lot of parts of the country.
It's like you and I do travel a lot.
There's not a lot of access to real good
food and there's access to,
to,
to different restaurant chains or
there's access to,
you know,
just a bunch of fast food and some areas
we can get healthier.
Supermarkets.
You can,
you can always,
but even then we'd get a tomato and it's
Pale.
This is white fucking tomato,
like what's in that type and hitting the
gas chamber.
That's how.
That's why not only that,
the genetics of the thing have
completely been altered so they can keep
them on a truck for a week,
you know?
It's a sort of the same thing that
they've done with,
with raw milk and I,
I know and people that are screaming at,
you know what we perceived the oldies,
Lloyd's and people from boom.
Raw Milk.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They're going to die anyway.
Look,
everyone's going to die.
You're gonna die too.
That's not the point.
I get what you're saying.
I know it logically.
You're correct,
ethically correct.
And I understand you're talking about
transparency.
You're talking about,
I'm talking,
I'm talking not just about transparency.
I'm talking that I'm saying that too
many people are telling too many people
what is and isn't okay to do.
That's a real problem.
And I always say that the law,
the way we should have law in this
country is,
could you imagine clint eastwood
arresting you for it?
If he had a gun and he pointed at you,
could you imagine the clinics?
We would arrest you for the credit
clinic square prints,
or you're growing hemp.
If you,
if you could you imagine dirty Harry,
where he breaks down hemp farms.
Tell and Oh,
we're you going to do it?
You're going to make food and clothes
the fuck you are getting a squad car.
If anything other than that is a
bullshit law.
Okay.
I could imagine dirty Harry arresting
these cons that are getting paid off by
Monsanto.
I can imagine.
Dirty Harry catching some scotch
drinking asshole,
you know,
in his Senate Room,
uh,
beating some hooker to death and he,
you know,
he walks in and you fuck,
I got Monsanto through and yeah,
right dead man.
You're a bad debt.
And he shoots him dead man Callahan and
you're happy.
You're happy that he shot the evil
Monsanto guy.
Yeah.
That's,
that seems like plenty.
Should might want to step in on this
one.
But could you see clinics with a rescue
for having a,
a roach in your car?
No.
No,
of course not.
He would maybe slap you and tell you.
Don't be stupid.
Don't be stupid kid.
Michael Pollan says you can vote three
times a day by what you put on your
plate.
Fuck,
yeah,
you go.
That's a good point.
Well,
that's why I've been telling people,
you know,
one day the stoners are going to unite
because there's a lot of a lot of
bullshit out there and you need to
respect the donor dollar.
I think the way of the future though is
probably genetically modified foods.
Ultimately.
Either way the future is.
I don't think we can see that many
people without.
Without funding,
we can find people with.
That's what I.
I don't know if that's true.
I don't believe it and I think as time
goes on,
the origin of those thoughts is profit.
I do not believe that the origin of
those thoughts is because we're really
concerned with feeding people because
that's not something that's not
something that you hear from the federal
government.
That's not something that was taken into
considerations.
When you,
when you look at how much money they
spend on defense contractors,
fucking billions and billions of dollars
on a daily basis,
on a yearly basis rather,
and defense contractors,
how much,
how much they spend feeding people.
Fucking zero.
Okay.
If they had the same resources that they
put into the military and they put that
into feeding people,
there would be incredibly successful in
feeding people so when they come along
and say,
we need genetically modified foods
because we need to feed people.
They're not trying to feed people.
They're not talking about feed people.
They want profit should all food,
all food has been genetically modified,
all of it.
Everything we do,
there's a difference between selective
breeding and growing and genetically
modifying.
They are changing things at the genetic
level to give them resistance to
pesticides.
But if you're doing a lot of shit out
there like golden rice,
which is very hot and fast,
well there's not.
It's not a yes or a no,
it's not yes or no.
That's what I'm saying that you're
right.
I think that the rise of technology,
even in food is inevitable.
There's a good side to it and they're.
There can also be an evil side to it.
And I think that,
um,
I think the question is transparency and
knowing and seeing all the data and
holding companies accountable and,
and realizing that technology is not a
bad thing.
It is a good thing.
We probably,
if we have 80 million people on this
planet in 50 years,
we're probably going to have to resort
to genetically modified foods.
We already are in some parts of the
world.
The question becomes how do you do it
responsibly and ethically,
the real issue is Paul risers character
from aliens is that country sneaky slimy
guy who wanted to bring the alien back
and use it as a biological weapon.
Yeah.
That was what was wrong with that
fucking mood.
That's what you call full circle as
jealous.
And that's what's wrong with lobbyists.
That's what's,
what's wrong with influencing the
congress to let something like this
sneak through where franken foods can be
in your,
your diet and you're not even aware of
it or the right.
I mean,
that's,
that's exactly right.
They were and even comes,
oh,
you know,
not what you're doing.
That matters.
Yeah.
And even people who might say,
well,
you're ignorant as to the effect of
genetically modified foods you're in.
You are absolutely right.
I have not read that much about
genetically modified foods.
I have read both pro and con.
I have heard like Carrie Santa Maria had
some very good points about genetically
modified foods and you have some very
good points and I've,
I've,
I've seen like at Penn Jillette had some
very good points.
He and I had a discussion about
genetically modified foods and I respect
his opinion as well.
It is not that this isn't the argument.
The argument is about transparency and
it's about the access to information and
about.
And it's about someone who is supposed
to be looking out for the interests of
the people,
allowing people to withhold information.
You should never do that.
You should just never do that.
You should never allow someone who's
selling something to withhold some weird
shit that they're doing to it that might
affect your health.
I want to know if I'm eating it has a
jelly bean,
a jellyfish,
a gene in it,
or it's after.
I want
to know that.
Tell me everything you know,
and this is sort of semi hypocritical
coming from me because I'm in the
supplement company,
you know what I mean?
I'm involved with with a supplement
company and then you take the
supplements you're taking.
There's also,
there's,
there's enough tangible data on the
subject that I'm confident in the
results and that I also have benefited.
I know that I've benefited from taking
supplements I've know that have
benefited.
I know that my health is pretty fucking
good and I know also a lot of it has to
do with diet.
A lot of it has to do with exercise and
a lot of it has to do with genetics,
no doubt about it,
but I am very confident.
I've gone through periods of have even
made experiments where have backed off
supplements and I get blood work done on
a regular basis.
I'm pretty aware of what the fuck's
going on and when my nutrients,
we're all at a very high level.
I function better.
I just do.
I know I do.
I have more energy and feel better.
You know,
when it's all done in conjunction,
but just not enough.
You know,
like if you,
if you look at the negative aspects of
that could possibly come from
supplementation.
There's not really enough information
about that.
Like how many,
how many,
uh,
vitamin D pills can you take before it's
makes you sick.
You know,
how many,
how many people take the wrong amount of
this,
how many people.
It's like,
it's a real trial and error thing unless
you're doing blood work.
So I always encourage people,
if you're interested in your health,
you got to know what the fuck is really
going on in your same ferris has get
blood work done,
don't take,
don't take guesses.
He found out he was low and I think my
rick acid and that's why I take coconut
oil.
The only place you can find,
I think it's called myrick or my silicic
acid.
The only place you can find it as in
sperm,
whale oil and coconut oil.
And I started taking it.
I gotta tell you man,
like I take a teaspoon or a tablespoon
in the morning.
I do,
but maybe a psychological,
but I feel better.
Man.
I feel better when I do things like the
Kale shakes I want to do,
but I juice Kale when I take a,
you know,
coconut oil is present and I know that
people are skeptical.
They were like,
oh,
maybe people are bullshitting.
Maybe this is just more in placebo
effect.
Maybe this is like,
it makes sense.
It's a drug man.
Treat it like it's not just that.
It's also like,
what exactly is your body?
Okay,
why does it need nutrients?
What is really going on?
What's this some sort of a chemical
process and it just stands to reason
that the more building blocks it gets
for repair,
for a killing,
you know,
taking out anti radicals,
free radicals for destroying free
radicals in your system for helping you
strengthen your immune system.
All those different things.
It just only makes sense that if the
machine has all it needs,
it will function better.
It did.
Did Tim Ferriss tell you?
I had him on the podcast and he said he,
he did.
Um,
he went to the blue zone and Okinawa and
see where they have the one area where
they live longer than anybody else.
Is it like a choral thing?
Nope.
He said,
he said he isolated.
He was interested in seeing what they
don't do.
One thing they don't eat rice.
Um,
they blue potatoes,
a blue potatoes.
Yes.
But he also said that I tried
to guess what they were,
but he said there are a couple of things
that they have that,
that very important for health one,
they never retire and too strong fucking
communities and,
and they always eat just enough.
There's a,
there's a saying for it.
I eat just enough.
I never,
I never stuff but mainly they think the
two main things and Malcolm Mcdowell
gladwell talks about this community is
fucking important for longevity,
community and never retiring.
Being interested in involved in
something is so important for your
health and it doesn't seem,
seems metaphysical.
It doesn't seem physical.
Like you know,
you can like this,
this,
this town,
Rosetta and heart disease in the
fifties,
in this country with epidemic,
they'd open up soldiers who are at at 21
and a lot of their car arteries were 80
percent clog.
It was epidemic.
They go to this place Rosetta,
which is this really tight Italian
community in Pennsylvania.
They Lard,
they were all overweight and none of
them were dying of heart disease.
They were all dying of old age.
Why?
The only thing they can isolate it was
the fact that they were such a tight
loving community that then maybe they
come from a really strong genetic stock.
They're all from the same part of Italy.
They took guys from Rosetta and who went
to other parts of the country.
They were dying of heart disease at the
same rate,
but when they were in this fucking
community,
they had such a strong tight bond within
that community and so much support.
They were just happy people.
It totally makes sense.
There's a physical aspect of human
interaction that there's.
There's a reaction,
there's something happening and there's
a need for it to the point where they
punish people in prison,
but taking it away from them.
If you don't touch a baby when they're,
when they're,
when they're between zero and one,
they will die.
It's called failure to thrive.
Hospitals have to have people come by
and hold the babies you cannot have.
They used to have an orphanage is they
put a baby and they wouldn't touch it
because they didn't want to give it a
disease.
They did that.
The baby would die.
That's called failure to thrive.
You don't hold the baby for a certain
amount of time during the day.
They will die.
Completely believed.
That totally makes sense that we don't
want to accept it as a.
it's an actual tangible,
measurable sort of a feeling or a thing,
but it's important.
Community is important.
You're not asleep.
You're not an island and we need each
other.
I mean,
when I think of all the good times,
and I think about that,
I was watching the hunting thing that
you and I go back so far.
I thought you feel so lucky when you
have friends that you have so many
experiences with you and I know each
other so fucking well,
you know,
so well,
like all the thorns and all.
It's just such a and watched.
We've grown up together,
you know,
that kind of stuff is,
is,
uh,
is priceless.
I mean everything else known you for
almost 20 years now.
Twenty years.
It'll be 20 years.
Next year.
Long ass time.
He stopped to think about how much crazy
shit we've seen together.
Yeah.
And you've saved me from making some
crazy decisions to,
you know,
you've saved me from going insane.
I mean,
I remember a meeting you,
it was like,
oh,
there's one out there I could hang with.
I grew up in a bunch of different places
in this country.
Uh,
you know,
from when I was a little kid lived in
San Francisco
and I live in Florida,
but I spent,
you know,
all through my high school years I
spent,
you know,
in Boston and one of the things about
Boston,
like I lived in a suburb,
Newton is he given that a lot of real
guys is a lot of guys who got up at 6:00
in the fucking morning and mowed lawns
before they came to school.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean there was,
there was,
there were men's men were,
there were actual men.
If someone talks some shit,
they wanted to go punch him in the face.
It was like growing up around them,
it was like there was,
these are normal people that I could,
if he told me a story,
I knew that's what happened,
or at least what he thinks it happened.
But I was getting mixed signals.
When I came to La.
I was like,
oh my God,
this is insane asylum.
I was totally ready to go back to New
York and if I didn't assign a fucking
lease from my apartment,
I thought my show was going to that
stupid baseball show.
Like I was an idiot.
I was 20 whatever years old to the
greatest show ever.
I'm thinking getting an apartment.
I can't fail.
And uh,
within,
you know,
four weeks I knew it was doomed and I'm
like,
fuck,
I got a fucking apartment.
I got an apartment for a year,
I want to get out of here.
I was like,
this is filled with crazy people and it
is by the way,
but I slowly but surely accumulated a
group of great friends.
It took forever.
It's like slowly grab guys like you,
okay,
come this way.
And then some show ideas.
Look at this guy.
Oh,
we gotta get him,
get in there.
It's really true.
You can I come to la,
la La.
It's like the,
you know,
the first,
uh,
my buddy said he was from New York and
he showed up at a party and he goes to
this party and there's this guy in a
robe with his arm around two girls on
couch and he goes like this.
He goes,
gentlemen,
welcome to my place.
Make yourselves at all.
He was like,
get me the fuck out of here right now.
I'm going to kick you in the face and
we're in a fucking robe.
Shit.
Hell yeah,
don't.
Yeah,
just try that in Boston or New York.
See how long you last with that shit.
Like,
my buddy was rock climbing.
We were rock climbing.
My buddies from California,
he was being a smart ass with them and
telling them what to do.
And my buddy was a wrestle.
My buddy turned him and goes,
hey,
you don't know you.
You sure as fuck don't know me.
And that's the last time I hear you
telling me to do anything.
And everybody got quiet.
And he was like,
well,
what the fuck?
What the fuck?
The Guy fucking threatened me.
I go,
that's right,
dude.
He threatened you physically because
you're being a fucking disrespectful
more on their guys out there that will
punch you in the fucking face if you
don't know how to behave.
There's a giant percentage of people who
grow up in this coast that they don't
know how to behave.
Never seen a fight.
What's.
Even if they have seen a fight,
they'd seen a fight between someone like
them and some of them.
I'm not talking about Mexicans either.
I'm talking about white guys not talking
about white guys in white guys in
Hollywood.
I'm not.
There are some tough.
There's some tough.
Like I know a lot of Latino guys.
Yeah,
out here who are tough as shit.
That's a whole different culture when
you're talking about is actors.
Yeah.
I'm talking about.
You're really talking about is nothing
to do with white guys,
but yeah,
there's some tough ass fucking regular
white dudes from California.
Well you're talking about is actor.
That's what it is.
Their loans.
They're fucking Limu and when I,
when I first met you,
I was like,
oh,
this guy's doing.
He's normal to or you're not normal.
You're certainly not normal,
but neither am I or was.
I was just honest about my interests,
which were because I'm a caveman.
Both dudes like we could talk.
We were two men.
I was like,
oh my God is another man.
I could talk to this man.
You know what's,
what's going on here?
I was like,
I feel I'm like,
what's with this fucking guy?
Ya Know?
These fucking people that were on the
set with you just said,
man,
tv were exhausting,
exhausting,
trying to be funny and clunky and
talking about their career.
Shut the fuck up.
My God.
What kind of self serving noises coming
out of that stupid head of yours,
like you don't even know that someone's
listening to you.
You can't even have a conversation.
You're not even a person.
You're one of those weird fucking actor
automatons.
I came to dinner one time and I had a
hat.
Turned backwards was fucking cool shit.
I looked in the mirror like 50 times
that day because I just had this new
hat.
I fucking sit down there and say,
well,
my father looked at me and he just goes,
done.
I go,
I'm good.
He goes,
yeah,
I can't do what he does.
He goes,
why are you wearing that hat?
I'm not anymore.
Just the way he said it,
I was like,
oh,
I fucking,
I'm an idiot.
But today if you wanted to do it,
you could pull it off.
Fuck.
Like now you're a different man.
Now you're self actualized.
Self realize now you could show up with
a bra on and like,
father you're,
you're missing a certain amount of
sophistication and worldliness,
torture my generation.
I mean I read books and wearing a,
it's like you can't fuck with us and a
scarf,
but you could laugh about that and it
would be great.
But if I was 21 and I was wearing a bra,
I was serious.
I was really trying to wear a bra like
fucking asshole.
Like what am I?
One of the like,
you know what I mean?
Like with those green,
not the what of those dudes that the,
the,
the Guardian angels remember that.
Of course,
dude,
I remember being in Boston and they just
made it to Boston were raise,
but yeah,
they were in New York for awhile and
they just made it to Boston and the guy
was walking around who's guardian
angels,
a t shirt on and this bra on and he's
walking and I look at him and I'm
following him and I'm locking eyes.
When he looked at me and goes,
fuck you.
He gave me the finger and I'm like,
well,
I didn't even say anything.
And you are a fucking guardian angel.
Really?
And then the guy who was the head of it,
who is a,
a radio dj guy now,
he like faked a rape.
He faked a where he helped someone and
he got shot,
you know?
Yeah.
But there was something that he faked.
Hold on,
I'll pull it up.
I don't want to slam over young man.
Curtis Silva,
I think his name is.
Yeah.
Fake story as quick story started.
The uh,
yeah,
I think that was horse shit.
Yeah,
I think,
uh,
I think that my courtesy was history of
lies and publicity stunts part one.
Ooh,
that's not good year.
He admitted to creating and perpetuating
at least six hoaxes over the years
between 1979 and 1980 according to the
December 14th,
1992 issue of people magazine because
that's.
Remember when he got in trouble and the
article sibyl recounts a October 1980
publicity stunt where he claimed he was
kidnapped by New York City transit
police and told if the Guardian Angels
Don't quit patrolling the subways,
they would kill him.
Everyone was against a silver plate and
explained the mayor of the cops.
Even the public.
We just needed some good attention.
Oh,
he's a fucking scam.
Artists,
you know,
if you're a scam artist once you're a
scam artist forever.
Fuck you.
You know,
this is just,
this is what he's doing.
I mean,
I guess,
can you bounce back from that?
Sure.
I'm going to try to do that with my
standup.
Somehow.
I'm going to be like,
I got arrested for making people laugh
too much.
They were pulling people out on fucking
out on stretchers.
This guy would have to bounce back
long way though,
man,
you know,
he would bounce.
He'd have to bounce back a long way
because this is.
He's had another guy I worked with them
who claimed that a fixed several
incidents,
including highly publicized rape of then
wife Lisa Silva,
Jesus,
whatever it is.
Yeah.
He's a.
any fake that too.
Yeah.
Wow.
It's.
Well,
they have a cabin.
They did shoot him,
I think in the legs or something.
Yeah.
Well,
whatever it is.
I mean,
who knows what happened.
He might have paid someone to do
something crazy to him.
Who knows?
Maybe it was just.
If you're doing this many bullshit
publicity stunts,
you're probably a really annoying guy.
Somebody will eventually actually does
want to shoot you.
It's really annoyed at you.
Silly Bitch.
But if I was wearing that Bra,
yeah,
smack me.
Well,
if I was 21 smack me.
You're not allowed to wear a bra.
Yeah.
Even today,
I can't pull off a boy.
No,
nobody can.
All right.
Unless you.
Randy coture,
unless you're a green baret,
unless you're a green beret or in the
French Foreign Legion that you can wear
a bra if you're in a Gi Joe to some
does.
He does the new Gi.
Joe,
does he have a brewery?
I think one of the guys like Falcon or
something.
If they're done well,
like I went to turn on teamwork around.
You've got a machine gun in your French
or you're in the French Foreign Legion
or something.
You can actually.
You look pretty good.
You have.
It is kind of.
Isn't that kind of funny that you're
like,
if you're a killer,
you're allowed to wear a bra.
Like that's when you're allowed to wear
the silliest hat ever.
We want you to wear the silliest had
ever because you're our best killer.
Like why don't give him a cat in the hat
hat?
Imagine that the fucking seat instead of
the Green Berets and see that cat in the
hat's just.
They're so gangster.
They don't give a fuck.
If you see that.
Hat's the Kombucha.
This is pretty funny.
Here's a.
here's a screenshot.
Gi Joe to the characters,
and then we got.
Hi Guys.
I'm wearing a bra here.
He doesn't look back.
No.
The Brian keeps saying that he has gay
accent.
Just stopped doing that voice.
That's Dennis Quaid.
It's so dumb.
He doesn't sound like him and you can't
keep repeating it.
It's not funny.
It's not true.
Agreed with me and nobody agreed with
you owe people that agreed with you.
Just wanted to talk to you.
They just wanted to reach out to you on
the Internet.
There.
Isn't that crazy test a bad dennis
quaid.
He's not.
He doesn't.
He doesn't think Dennis Quaid sounds
like a a,
a South Park character really?
Well,
what he did sound like in that movie,
you're talking about that today after
tomorrow was totally fake it.
That's absolutely true.
It was like a.
It was such a super fake movie.
That is his acting sucked.
It was.
It was a terrible movie.
I mean the day after tomorrow,
it's.
It's almost impossible to do and not be
ridiculous.
What have you seen that you love besides
les miserables?
What have you seen that I got injected,
injected into my asshole with a laser
beam.
I didn't.
I wouldn't watch on the screen.
I want to experience it through my
central nervous system,
asshole first.
And uh,
I love you.
I came,
I came in my own mouth.
It's my,
my calm.
I opened my mouth and it was like
crescendo.
The jet came out of my cock that was the
exact shape of my mouth on the inside
and it went in seamlessly.
It was an air tight airtight seal gallon
of calm,
just like,
like,
like a wiffle ball bat suspended from
the tip of my dick out in a fan shape of
my mouth and went right in the hole.
You haven't,
you have to sit through a fucking
musical.
One time I remember you told me what was
like,
he goes,
it was a murderer.
Attention on my murders,
assault my attention span.
Yeah.
I had a friend that was a in a musical
and we all went and we watched the first
half and then I was like,
what do you guys think?
And they're like,
well,
I think she's doing a really great job,
but think it was awesome.
And I said,
that was a fucking murderers assault on
your attention span.
How dare you pretend you'd like that?
Nobody could possibly like that.
When you're watching nonsense,
you're watching songs that suck for no
reason.
Someone's singing songs for no reason
and those songs are fucking terrible.
This shit doesn't make any sense.
Shut your mouth.
You shut your mouth.
You're not enjoying it.
It'd be weird if I started singing now
to tell you she's what?
Joe,
y'all my friend that was like,
they drop their jaw so I get embarrassed
when I eat.
When I see those things were all of a
sudden the guy starts to sing.
Well,
what about the time that you had an
acting class?
Brian and international.
And it was in the.
Did I?
Okay.
Was Brian and acting class?
And it was,
he had a,
the teacher was singing show tunes and
Brian called me up and he says,
you have to come to this.
My teacher is going to sing,
show tunes.
London's it.
So I,
I went,
I found Brian and me and him just like
cuddled up like a couple of retards,
like,
oh my goodness,
this is the most ridiculous thing I've
ever seen.
He was singing,
he was a,
you know,
he was a guy,
he's a great guy,
but he just loved show tunes,
fucking love them and,
and,
and very straight.
And uh,
I was,
I was so fascinated.
I was like,
you love musicals.
He loved them.
You know,
I sat through a musical,
a musical theater class,
you know,
that.
Did I ever tell you that your teacher,
was he?
Yes.
I was so obsessed with.
So I was like,
I gotta see who loves this stuff.
I,
I get obsessed with that stuff.
I see in the insanity and I'll get
involved in it.
Man,
I enjoyed it.
Wrong reasons what you and I had a great
fucking time then,
right?
It was really a good laugh.
Yeah,
he was great.
I had the lyrics of his song stuck in my
head for so many years because it was so
bad.
It was like show tunes though.
She says,
may you have a training when you are
thirsty and needed really literal songs
on the nose.
Really bad it was,
but it was like one of those where it's
like,
she's gone away.
Me,
you have a Sun News Da,
you have a hug when you need a hug,
we should do a music.
Oh No,
we shouldn't ask.
No hunting now.
I really enjoyed the book of Mormon that
was allowed.
It was great.
It's really good,
but I liked their movies better.
How about that?
Even even even the best case scenario
when a bunch of people are singing
theater guy now south like South Park,
the movie is still to this day,
I think like one of the greatest comedy
special or comedy movies,
et Cetera.
Thirty call me up that,
you know,
I've never seen it.
I'm like,
God,
that's so crazy.
Team America never.
Oh my God,
I have to write what is wrong with you?
I'm going to do that.
That's what I'm going to write that
down.
Yeah,
because and it was because it was so
ridiculous in team America was also a
musical.
There was a lot of musical elements to
it.
It was like a,
it was a little bit of music and then a
lot of acting sort of like,
even like the book of Mormon.
Isn't that the one where Sean Penn got
really mad at them for making fun of a.
didn't have a lot of things that.
Come on,
Shaun,
you got to take shawn uptight.
He needs a hug.
Well,
it's against.
He's a fucking actor.
There's no getting around that man.
The best actors,
the most,
the coolest ones to hang out with are
still not nearly as interesting as your
average landscaper.
Right?
So fact,
why am I podcast?
I never have actors.
I always want to have like,
you know,
other people,
like somebody who writes a book or a or
a soldier.
I don't know.
Somebody,
a lawyer,
you know,
it's more interesting to me.
Yeah,
I remember I was listening to an
interview and uh,
I think Brad Pitt's an awesome actor,
no doubt about it.
But it was like I was listening,
I was like on CNN and I wasn't paying
attention on care and I was like,
who is this idiot that Larry King's
talking to Brad attack?
It doesn't mean he's going to make them
believe.
And that's what it doesn't mean he's got
charisma is great to look at.
It doesn't mean I'm going to listen to
his point of view on life.
I,
you know what also I think that the,
the ability to transform yourself into
another person like you know,
doesn't necessarily lend itself to you
being in an eloquent public speaker and
representative of,
of your craft.
A little.
Probably a Weirdos like,
oh,
you mean because Daniel Day Lewis lived
in a log cabin with no electricity
through the whole time he shot Lincoln.
Hey Dude still sucked.
That's gotta suck when you do that,
when you spend so much time.
Still the fucking shit out of him with
the box.
We trained for three years to be a
boxer.
For me,
I got good and I watched.
I was like,
well,
you could've done the movie without
being a boxer.
Actually it wasn't.
It wasn't that it wasn't like the
deciding factor,
but it wants to him,
man,
he is that guy.
Christian Bale said it the best.
They said,
why do you lose weight or you've put
yourself through all this crazy shit.
He goes,
you know why I do that stuff,
dude.
I make believe I wear makeup for a
living.
It doesn't make me feel like a man,
so I got to make it really fucking
difficult on myself.
It was great answer.
Do it needs a hug too.
They all need hugs.
Okay,
mark and mark doesn't have that a to and
looking at me.
What you guys want?
Attitude and you want to laugh.
You come to San Antonio,
Ella,
laugh out loud.
Comedy club Friday,
Saturday and Sunday,
lol,
and listen to the 10 minute podcasts and
Brian Cowen show.
I'm out 35 because that's a good way to
end this thing.
Let's fucking wrap it up.
This or this.
Saturday night,
I'll be in Indianapolis,
Indiana with young Tony Hinchcliffe.
Take it.
Tony out in the road break is a little
comedy.
Booty break is cherry and he's chairman.
Cliff Pricey.
What is that?
That's how you spell his last name.
Oh,
silly.
Um,
so that's a,
that's a Saturday night.
Indianapolis News,
New Brunswick,
New Jersey.
I'm pretty sure it's sold out.
And I think San Jose sold out too.
So Sam,
Shawn Rogan,
Joe Rogan experience.
That's my walking dead voice every time
I see you.
And then I see me.
We've set something.
Could've been brothers.
Oh easily.
Well everybody in my house by the way.
My parents watched the mediator episodes
they want to because they were kind of
freaked out about Michela dear.
A little.
A little odd to see them watch those it
with a hatchet,
like chip open the fucking rib cases.
Pretty intense stuff.
But um,
they were like,
do you guys look like the closest two
brothers you ever have?
Like as you get older you really look
like brothers.
I kept,
like I was saying,
is that job or that strange?
I'm better looking at times a little
sexier.
You're a little sexier.
Rogan.ting.com.
Pitches go there.
Save yourself $25,
put it in your mouth,
putting your mouth and his balls.
That doesn't make any sense.
I'm sorry Tim,
you don't deserve that for your
commercial Rogan.ting.com.
Go there and save yourself to $25 off
either a phone or service.
An excellent company that supports the
podcast so police support them.
We were also brought to you by square
space and uh,
I think it is squarespace.com
forward slash Joe.
And I think,
uh,
I think it's the code is joe three right
for now.
Probably Joe Fournier.
It doesn't work,
dude.
Joe Three.
Yeah.
Be Creative if it doesn't work just to
figure it out.
Your dirty fucks,
but go to squarespace and support them.
Easy,
easy website setup and awesome.
I want Dolphin bought a whole.
He put that shit together while this
show is going on,
ladies and gentlemen.
Okay.
I mean it's really that ridiculous and
he probably will maintain it too.
It's so easy.
Throw some pictures up there.
Every now and then and people.
Only people who listen to this episode
will know about this.
Register that.
Hurry quickly use hover to register it.
I want often butthole.com.
Don't get.org
because then you can't profit legally.
I think I made that up.
Get Dot net.
Be Clever.
Be Different.
Be indie.
Go also to squarespace.com.
Forward Slash Joe.
Right?
So what it is,
do we figured it out?
Yeah,
I'm,
yeah,
go there.
Go to squarespace.
You Fox.
Get a case of a God damn website.
We're all out of the chimp kettlebells
at [inaudible] dot com.
But we got more common and like I said,
a lot more cool shit headed your way and
if you think of any cool shit that we
need to have in the store,
fucking let us know about it.
Pills settled down.
Sign those gas stations.
You can't sell it legally over the
Internet.
The CIALIS,
Chinese mixtures sold from Canada.
Powerful bra you for being on.
Okay.
And you or are also not as awesome as
you mentioned the awesomest ever.
So it's impossible to be anymore.
Awesome.
So what'd you said?
Makes no so powerful.
Bra Bird Ban were here this weekend.
Cupcakes.
Ice House Friday.
Powerful ice house Friday.
Who's going to be there with you?
I don't know yet.
Powerful lineup though.
There's always really funny comics in
town.
I mean it's La in Pasadena ice houses,
all this comedy club in the country.
As far as I know it really far.
Yeah.
It's been around for 50 years and I
liked the big robot.
We just did the little room last Friday
night.
It's fucking amazing.
Yeah.
Hey,
we love the shit out of people and we'll
see you tomorrow with Douglas Rushkoff.
I'm a brilliant author and a really
interesting guy,
and we're gonna.
We're gonna.
Have some really cool conversation
tomorrow with Douglas.
A Google them.
If you don't know what the fuck is.
What am I?
Your mom sockets.
So you fucks tomorrow.